this episode is brought to you by Nordic
Naturals the number one selling fish oil
brand in the US more than 80% of
Americans that's probably a lot of you
listening including me because I do
measure my Omega-3s do not get enough
omega-3 fats from their diet that is a
problem because the body cannot produce
Omega-3s an important nutrient for cell
structure and function Nordic Naturals
solves that problem with their doctor
recommended and in fact this brand was
recommended to be by one of my doctors
ultimate omega fish oil formula so the
Ultimate Omega fish oil formula for
heart health brain function immune
support and more it's incredibly pure
and fresh with no fishy aftertaste so I
have been taking Ultimate Omega for the
last two months or so and this fishy
aftertaste issue has been a problem for
me and has actually with other brands
induced some nausea after a few days and
Ultimate Omega has been as clean as a
whistle I've had no issues whatsoever
and if you are vegetarian or prefer to
alternate I ended up alternating two
products and that is number one the
Ultimate Omega fish oil formula and also
the algae Omega which is plant-based EPA
and DHA that's also from a Nordic
Naturals so I end up getting both of
those products and it has improved my
recovery from workouts it's improved my
sleep it has improved my mood and I know
that because I pulled out a lot of other
variables in any case back to the read
all Nordic Naturals fish oil products
are offered in the triglyceride
molecular form the form naturally found
in fish and the form your body most
easily absorbs their ultimate omega fish
oil is offered in soft gels liquid and
zero sugar gummies Nordic Naturals fish
oils are friend of the C certified and
sustainably made in a zero waste
facility powered by biofuel they're also
non-GMO and third party tested
surpassing the strictest International
standards for Purity and freshness want
proof you can visit their website where
they they provide certificates of
analysis for every one of their products
so go to
this product is not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any
disease this episode is brought to you
by givewell there are more than 1.5
million nonprofit organizations in the
United States and millions more around
the world it is very hard to separate
the single from the noise what I mean by
that is how do you know which few could
actually make a big impact with your
donation rather than frittering it away
with operational expenses and
ineffective initiatives well givewell
has done the hard work givewell was
founded to help donors answer that
question precisely they pour over
independent studies and charity data to
help donors direct their funds to
evidence-backed organizations that are
saving and improving lives givewell has
now spent more than 15 years researching
charitable organizations and they only
direct funding to a few of the highest
impact opportunities that they found in
global health and poverty alleviation
more than 100,000 donors including yours
truly have used givewell to donate more
than1 billion dollar which includes $7
45,9 donated by you my dear listeners so
thank you for that compelling evidence
suggests that these donations will save
more than
150,000 lives and improve the lives of
millions more give well wants as many
donors as possible to make informed
decisions about high impact giving and
you can find all of their research and
recommendations on their website for
free you can make tax deductible
donations to their recommended funds or
Charities and givewell does not take a
cut if you've never donated through
givewell before definitely check it out
you should absolutely take a look at it
you can have your donation also matched
up to $100 before the end of the year or
as long as matching funds last so to
claim your match and to learn more go to
givewell dorg and pick podcast and enter
the Tim Ferris show at check out make
sure that they know you heard about give
well from the Tim Farah show to get your
donation matched one more time that's
give well g i w lgw well.org to learn
more or donate
optimal this altitude I can run flat out
for a half mile before my hands start
shaking can I ask you a personal
question now we see the time what I'm a
cybernetic organism living dissue over
metal
endoskeleton
hello boys and girls ladies and germs an
all this is Tim Ferris and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferris show
this episode is a bit of an anomaly a
bit of a highlight for me it deviates
from the usual format I am interviewing
a worldclass performer in this case my
good friend Steve Jang who is one of
those people one of those Tech Founders
and entrepreneurs and investors who
seems to be able to look around corners
to see things before they go main stream
and he has an impeccable record but in
this particular sitdown we are in person
in Soul South Korea I had wanted to
visit Korea for 20 plus years and had
never pulled the trigger finally did I
always wanted to go with a friend who
could show me around and Steve Jang is
such a person and and Korea exceeded
every expectation on every level in
every Dimension it really blew my mind
and so I wanted to do an episode
discussing all things Korea so in this
conversation we talk about the kwave
that is the exploding soft power of
Korea which is not accidental by the way
the poverty to power Playbook so to
speak how did they go from I don't want
to say a Backwater but a very
handicapped economically handicapped
country
to being an incredible export economy
with a global presence not just in
entertainment but in Hardware in all
sorts of Technology ETC number of
Concepts like Han mustsee movies and
much more and before we dive into
Steve's bio I wanted to share his top
mustsee Korean movies so I'm just going
to list them out give you some Scooby
Snacks in the very beginning here we go
old boy whaling that's w a i l i n so
old boy wailing the handmaiden memories
of murder parasite many of you will have
seen this and this comes up in the
conversation burning minadi m i n a r i
broker which is from 2022 and Joint
security area all right so who is Steve
Jang you can find him on Twitter at
Steve Jang j n g Steve is the founder
and managing partner at Kindred Ventures
an early stage Venture Capital fund
based in San Francisco he is one of the
founder now investor generation of VCS
that arose out of the last technology
cycle and he and I have been advisers to
a lot of the same companies invested in
a lot of the same companies he is very
very good at what he does Steve is one
of the top 100 Venture Capital investors
in the world according to the Forbes
mest list of top Venture Capital
investors and was ranked number 45 in
2023 he's also a Korean American a goo
we'll explain what guo is who is deeply
invested and involved in both both the
technological and cultural world in the
US and Asia he is often a bridge
previously Steve was an early adviser to
and angel investor in Uber and then an
early stage investor in some names you
might recognize coinbase Postmates
Poshmark tonal Blue Bottle Coffee and
Humane the AI device platform that is
getting a lot of Buzz right now in fact
he helped Uber coinbase and Blue Bottle
Coffee among others to expand into Korea
and Japan he is very familiar with both
places as an Entre preneur Steve
co-founded companies in the consumer
internet mobile and crypto space and on
top of all of that in the film and music
world he is an executive producer his
most recent film is a documentary Nam
Jun Pike moon is the oldest TV which
tells the story of the greatest Korean
artist and father of digital video art
which premiered at the Sundance Film
Festival in 2023 his next film is a
documentary about vitalic butterin the
creator of ethereum you can find Steve
on Twitter as I mentioned at Steve Jang
you can find Kindred Adventures at
Kinder adventures.com and you can find
Steve on LinkedIn at Steve jang1 and now
without further Ado thanks for your
patience folks please enjoy this very
wide- ranging conversation that I loved
held live in person in Soul South
Korea so Steve Jen nice to see you sir
good to see you thanks for having me AB
absolutely so talking to
you welcome to the
te I'm thrilled to be here because I've
wanted to visit Korea for 20 plus years
it's wild that you haven't been here yet
I've been in the so airport multiple
times on route to Japan doesn't count
doesn't count doesn't count and then I
was on a flight as I often am and I
watched a few things I watched the movie
Past lives which which is excellent
movie strongly recommend amazing and
then watched since I was sort of getting
tapped for the Korea high after watching
that movie I went to a K-pop documentary
which was also in the inflight menu very
well done and as soon as I got off the
flight I think that's when I texted you
and I was like Steve when are you taking
me to Korea and you're like actually I'm
going to be in Korea yeah and that is
how I pulled the trigger bought a ticket
and we find ourselves here and soul has
exceeded and the Korean people and the
Korean language on all levels have
exceeded my expectations and the
question that kept popping into my mind
is why aren't more people coming here
why aren't more people talking about
soul in the same way that people talk
about Tokyo for instance why don't we
just maybe start there and we'll see
where things go it's really because of
that kwave that you described mhm has
happened recently very recently I mean I
think people have been fascinated by
going to Japan and going to on sense in
Kyoto and Tokyo and experiencing all
that for 3 four decades now yeah and
it's become a favorite for people who
love Eastern culture they love design
food in Tokyo and Kyoto are are amazing
right and then Beijing Shanghai Hong
Kong have been on the map for a century
mhm Korea was a developing country you
have to remember that from 1905 to
1945 it was annexed and colonized by
Japan right and so it was a poor country
mhm it was in an oppressed state so it
wasn't a place that you would want to
visit right as an outsider and then the
Korean War happens and the country is
destroyed and split into two again not
something you want to visit but it had
the fastest rate of economic growth of
any country across three decades after
that and so what happened there is that
it was an industrial country that was
still rough that was still trying to
rebuild and again not a place that you
would go for tourism not a place that
you would go to experience culture but
that really changed in the 80s you
started to see Korean movies and music
become something that was very unique
and very Korean and not something that
was sort of formulaic from another
country and so I think in the 9s is when
K-pop really started to become a thing
and expand outward and there was a
diaspora Happ happening of Korean
immigrants going outward especially to
the US but also for decades going into
the Middle East because of industrial
jobs and the labor needs of those
countries South America has one of the
largest Korean diaspora populations you
go to Brazil Chile Colombia there's a
lot of Koreans in South America and then
in Europe France and the UK are and
Germany were also Landing spots so all
of this is happening more recently in
time yeah the main actor or one of the
main actors Korean actors in past lives
name is ta ta yeah ta was born in
Germany yeah
and what do you call Koreans overseas
goo what is it goo goo it was kind of a
I don't want to say a derogatory term
that Koreans had for Koreans who left
but it had sort of a negative
connotation I remember it was a little
bit of a negative connotation when I was
in Korea in the ' 80s and '90s as a kid
and then now it's become like fully
accepted it's an accepted and used and
practical term right it's not something
that is considered negative anymore so I
want to highlight something that you
said which
is this rate of growth I've observed for
instance in Soul that the taxis the
actual cars look like something out of
Blade Runner in many cases they're very
futuristic this is a very futuristic
town and you put a post on Instagram
with a video of this robot that was sort
of being defended by this Bodyguard from
I guess the kts or KBS rather and it is
very much a glimpse I feel into the
future of sworts when you visit Soul
certain portions of soul in contrast if
you go to say Japan the taxis look like
they're many many and they are many many
decades old if I compare my experience
when I was say in Japan in
1992 to my experience in Japan
now my perception is cuz I've been back
many times not that much has changed
certainly things have changed but it's
not dramatic how would you compare like
the last 10 20 30 years in Korea and
maybe technology penetration is one way
to unpack this but you were talking
about for instance even from a
socioeconomic perspective like the some
of the poorest people will still have
technological access that would Trump
most of what people experience in the US
there are definitely modern parts of
what is happening here in the economy
and the society but it's a city of
opposites I see the modern parts that
you see but I think that there's also a
dichotomy between the old and the Decay
as well as this very modern very
futuristic aspect in one city in one
country it's a city in transition it's a
country in transition we walked around
neighborhoods where these were built
buildings that were 100 years old and
then we saw buildings that were recently
put up with steel and glass and with
giant LED
screens this balance or this sort of
conflict that you see out there is
really a function of something that
didn't happen in Japan really I think
Japan rebuilt very quickly after World
War II and became modern very quickly
for Korea it's really in the last couple
of decades that this has happened
and it's happened in a way where Koreans
are holding still on to the past there
are cafes that are beautiful
cafes that are built in bombed out shoe
factories and it has so much character
and history it kind of reminds me of
When I visit Berlin that vintage classic
architecture almost brutal from that era
and then very modern Progressive
concepts of architecture and culture
coexisting together and I see a lot of
similari between Berlin and soul more
than I would see it in let's say Hong
Kong and soul and in Tokyo it's like you
said the taxi cabs are Classic Cabs they
are Immaculate they are Immaculate mm in
Korea the taxi cabs are changing by the
day is you know it's this new hyai car
this Kia car and they're very modern but
they're almost disposable at this point
because they're cycling through cars
very quickly and so there's this sort of
rush or need to constantly
innovate and improve here that doesn't
hold on to the classics very well and so
I actually like to see a lot of the old
school classic things still thriving
here and I hope that it doesn't go away
because it's part of the history it's
what makes Koreans really interesting
today because like all the K-pop and the
movies that you see they're all rooted
in the past mhm and they're trying to do
something new in the future this Korean
diaspora again we called goo has fanned
out globally and we're always sort of in
between we're not fully American or
British or French we're Korean American
we're Korean French we're Korean British
you're always a hyphenated thing and
then when you're back here it used to be
that people could pick you out they
could pick you out by how you walked not
even how you spoke but how you walked
and looked at people and your body
language your hairstyle how you dressed
and they could pick you out as a
foreigner mhm now it's become a lot more
of a in andout revolving door of
different influences and foreigners so
it's become a lot more modern but still
there's a very much a Korean way to that
and I think that what's become very
interesting over watching sort of the
last 30 years of development has been
this Embrace of outside influences Korea
was called The Hermit Kingdom I remember
going to Korean school in Los Angeles
when I grew up every Saturday
when everyone else was watching cartoons
or playing soccer I went to Korean
school from 8:00 a.m. to 1:00 p.m. I
went to vanise high school public school
and this Korean School rented from the
LA Unified School District and we'd go
there we'd learn hung we'd learn how to
write and read and then you had a choice
of an elective Abacus calligraphy tondo
and the fan dance so I picked tondo and
I tried advocus I tried calligraphy
really enjoyed it so the things that
stuck for me were Teo and
calligraphy this is my Saturday for 8
years so you're trying to preserve some
of that learning and culture as you go
out now imagine in Korea historically in
the shadow of China and then more
recently in the times in the 20th
century under military rule and
annexation by Japan for them in that
time period under Japanese rule it was
very harsh many Koreans were killed or
forced to move to Japan to survive and
make their way but part of it was they
were not allowed to speak Korean they
were not allowed to write in Korean they
were forced to take Japanese names and
so there was a whole diaspora that went
to Japan in the 19th century but also
largely in the 20th century so there are
a lot of Koreans ethnic Koreans that
live in Japan but it's a LoveHate
relationship today that I see with Japan
yeah they trading partners their
neighbors their allies when it comes to
Outsiders but there's a lot of
historical beef between them but there's
a lot of appreciation and love too
especially in the younger Generations
especially in the younger Generations I
mean when I was in high school and moved
from a public school to a private school
and I had the chance to start studying
Japanese a number of my friends in high
school were Korean and and pretty Korean
Korean like not korean-american like
they had come to the US just to go to
school and then they went back to Korea
generally or went to college and then
went back to Korea and the fact that I
didn't have the historical context but
the fact that I was studying
Japanese really bothered some of my
friends parents I remember like we went
on a drive and the fact that like I was
so excited to be studying Japanese was
not exciting to one of my friends
parents example they were also quite a
bit older but they had been their
personal experience was just so
different from mine they have really
like fresh memories Super Fresh of the
annexation and the colonial rule so let
me throw out a couple things that stand
out to me here as super interesting
facets in Korea the demonstrations which
maybe we'll get to there's that's
something I don't see as much of in a
place like Japan I would say almost
certainly it's not something you see as
much of in China you you see
demonstrations everywhere but I've seen
a lot of demonstrations here there are
also a lot of preachers with or at least
a handful preachers with megaphones so
you have a is it predominantly Christian
Society here it's I think other than the
Philippines is the only predominantly
Christian Asian country okay so that's
point one which is certainly true like
if you drive around La right a number of
Korean churches buses taking Koreans to
churches like there's that component
I've heard Korea described and I have no
education related to this but I've heard
Korea described as I was coming here and
doing reading as the most
Confucian country in East Asia right
right so maybe what does that mean for
people who are like what does that
actually mean it's sort of when you talk
about a a species of animal that has
gone off to cross the body of water and
goes to a new continent or a new island
yeah and then everything changes on the
origin continent and then somehow the
strain of plant or this species of
animal has continu toist it's a very
unique thing now right and and because
it hasn't been influenced from the
outside like the origin point and So
Korea received the Confucian value
system filial piety a strong strong
focus on education and academics and
scholarship which came from China but
China went through its changes in the
20th century right Cultural Revolution
and a lot of the classical Chinese
Concepts were removed for something more
modern and populist and So Korea is sort
of the last Bastion of this Confucian
idealism in this way and I think that's
where you get a lot of this people talk
about the Korean education system and
academics and the pressures there's a
lot of you know downsides and trade-offs
for people and and that really comes
from that like even growing up in
La you know I was born in Korea we
immigrated over to Los Angeles it was
very much this very pedantic academic
thing that was forced and you see hugw
on which are Korean tutoring centers
that you won't see this anywhere else we
have friends in different cities that
have kids there's nothing like the
Korean hugan which is the Korean word
for a tutor or a tutoring center a
tutoring school when school is is done
you go to another school also just to
underscore when school is done so I was
listening to this interview with a
Korean language teacher somewhere in
Oxford I think and they asked her how
she would describe the difference
between School in say the UK and school
in Korea and she said oh students in the
UK or English is pretty rough and she's
like they's so much happier she said
they end school at 300 p.m. she said in
Korea I ended school at 10: p.m. and
then I went to the I mean the really int
Hagan right the the cramp school which
also exists Juku in in Japan but it it
seems more intense here actually it
seems it's more intense here because she
was saying I would come home from my
regular school like 910 then go to cram
school come home at 1:00 a.m. and then
just repeat that that sounds very
extreme that was her vibe that is
Extreme well I mean even the kopo mhm
Korean diaspora the Korean immigrants
that move out they create that
in their Landing City in Seattle in San
Francisco San Jose Oakland Los Angeles
Chicago Atlanta Atlanta has one of the
largest korean-american populations New
York is the second largest
korean-american population second to Los
Angeles but if you go to these cities
there's a whole network of
businesses and Hogans that are owned and
operated by korean-american immigrants
and the churches are the landing point
to connect with your community so when
you move over you may not have any
friends or relatives they would go to
the church they might not have even been
very religious but it was the immigrants
sort of Ellis Island of that City
meeting point to get connected to people
that look like them and spoke like them
and understood them that makes sense but
the hog ones are a very particular
Korean thing and I have a friend minin
Lee who's the author of Pachinko which
is an Incredible Book I've heard great
things about from multiple people I will
admit this wholeheartedly that it's one
of the few books where I just
immediately am like in tears reading
because it touches not only the history
of Korean people but also Koreans who
moved out gilo all right and it takes
place in Japan it's during the early
20th century and it follows a
generational story about a family that's
living in hardship in Japan my mother's
side actually was educated and raised in
Japan
no kidding I did not know that and so I
have a different View and experience
with that Korean Japanese relationship
through history all the pictures all the
photos the old we have old photos in my
parents home of my great-grandfather and
my great great grandfather my dad's side
they're in very southern tip of Korea
and they're wearing very Korean peasant
clothing and you can tell it's 1800s
Korea and then my mother's side is
wearing a three-piece suit with a fedora
a bowler hat and a neatly trimmed
mustache and is clearly living in Japan
and they lived in Tokyo and Kyoto and so
I have a very sort of
ambivalent complicated thing I love
going to Tokyo I have a lot of Japanese
friends I have Japanese startup
portfolio Founders and I love chatting
with them so for a younger generation of
Koreans and Japanese there's great
Harmony and diversity in that and people
move back and forth between soul and
Tokyo as easily as we move between like
San Francisco and LA or New York and San
Francisco but it's interesting to see
those influences and I think when you
look at the things that you've seen mhm
in your deep understanding of Japanese
culture and language and Chinese culture
and language you will see that there
influences you may not know the origin
point but you're like that word sounds
very similar mhm but the where it
diverges is it's these unique phrases
and words that capture part of the
feeling or the psyche in the soul of
those people yeah that is really
fascinating totally and we were talking
about this so explain what natsukashi is
in Japanese language yeah so natosi is a
beautiful word by the way I love your
pronunciation thank you better than a
lot of n in the US yes natashi you'll
run into this a lot in Japan and when
someone comes Ross something that is
nostalgic which nostalgic is not a word
that gets used much in the US but it's a
literary word not a exactly in the US
you might say oh man that brings back
the memories or something like that
which is a little bit closer to natashi
it's also a little closer to saaj in
Brazilian Portuguese has a similar
feeling to it butash they' be
like is is Pleasant Nostalgia when
something brings back the memories
positive positive right that word
doesn't exist in K
language yes so you need you need to say
more
so so we have things that revolve in
Korean language around suffering and
pain sorrow regret sorrow rage
oppression
angst it's the way I describe to people
who have been to Tokyo a lot and they
ask they go should I go to Soul I'm like
absolutely it's so fun it's so electric
right now the ideas are new they're
embracing outside influences you should
go now cuz you will miss it when it's
fully dialed in like going to be
unrecognizable 5 or 10 years from now
right it's just moving so quickly I mean
I come like three four times a year and
I don't feel the differences between
each of those times but I can look back
and say oh three four years ago these
things did not exist these of even going
on some of our walks in these
neighborhoods that you hadn't been to
yeah I walked in that neighborhood that
I took you to songong I brought the blue
bottle brought one of the Blue Bottle
Coffee Founders and we had both invested
in that company a long time ago and they
were interested to come to Japan and
Korea so I met up with them in Japan
walked around different Tokyo
neighborhoods with them came to Soul did
the same they fell in love with that
neighborhood cuz it had that
very like classic old school vintage
this is real Korea real Soul it's a
beautiful walking area really nice and
you saw it there's actually real
painters out with their easel painting
nature and streets and life it's so fun
to see that but when you see that you'll
think oh it's just like Tokyo right
because it's very quaint it's very
precise it's very safe unbelievably
clean also but there are and
butts if you spend more than a few days
here in Soul you'll realize that what
you are looking at is a city that might
on the outset look like you're walking
into Tokyo but is actually the other
side of the coin they exist in the same
Dimension but is a very different vibe I
think you were talking where we talking
this might have been after a little bit
of Soju but always it's like the Bizarro
like when I used to watch the Superman
cartoons like in the mornings before
going to school or whatever there was
like Bizarro Superman who is like looked
just like Superman but I like wait a
second that's not Superman yeah yeah
it's different yeah it's like the in
stranger things they call it the upside
down yeah right yeah so the culture here
is less polite in the protocol
definition of the word yeah in Japan it
is very difficult for a Japanese person
to say no very directly and bluntly to
you mhm very hard cuz it's very impolite
for them to do that it's almost a
dishonor for them to behave that way
towards you yeah so just side note for
folks if you ever have ask a Japanese
person to do anything this could be at
your hotel or whatever if they scratch
their head and they go and they breathe
in like that or they
go if they say it's difficult that means
no that means impossible generally if
they start apologizing right away yeah
then you know it's not going to happen
right yeah the word like where which
gets translated literally into English
and no like you almost never hear that
word very rarely heard when I'm in Japan
I have to
definitely take on a much more reserved
and polite stance more than I would in
the US more than I would even in Korea
because of that and I respect
that in Korea there's still a little bit
of that I'm smirking so hard because I'm
thinking you're doing less child's pose
in the tea houses when you have a low
back
pain went to this he's so cute adorable
tea houses just a with this little like
you had the like little Courtyard in the
Middle with the manicure trees and poor
Steve his low back was killing him and
so he's stretching but it's kind of in
the hallway and these two women just
glitched so hard cuz they didn't know
how to contend with it but yeah it's my
fault and because I'm still an American
at heart and so what we're talking about
here is is is the other part of me my my
family's history but so I have to try
right because it's that different
totally and so in Korea they're much
more likely to say no they're much more
likely to challenge you directly much
more likely to say Mr chairman you need
to eat less yeah in a sarcastic way call
me Mr chairman you probably should go on
a diet so your back doesn't hurt which
is you know I love my food but I I
really didn't need to hear that from the
well-meaning AA with the yaka perm so
the experience that people will have is
that it's not as lonely as it might be
with being an exat in Japan my wife
lived 10 years as an expat in Tokyo and
when we were dating I'd visit her a lot
and before that I would visit Tokyo a
lot cuz I had an investor there and we
were working on something and so I was
there frequently for years
and I got to understand a little bit
about the experiences of her and her
expat friends it's one part elevated
because they're expats they're
foreigners but one part sort of they're
not part of main society right and so in
Korea and especially in cities and you
have to make a distinction between the
countryside in Korea rural areas in
smaller towns and then soul and Pan the
big cities it's a very different
experience you may not enjoy
living in a small town in Korea because
it really is you know still stuck in
that 60s and 7s environment both from a
material aspect and utilities and just
lifestyle it's very modern in the cities
so there's a really harsh divide to the
point where everyone wants to move to
the big city and so these smaller towns
are emptying out and there's a big
problem with that there's some pluses to
that but there's some really strong
minuses as well yeah but the foreigners
feel like it's easier to integrate here
maybe integrates the wrong word but they
feel more welcome I think it's so
difficult to integrate in any of these
cities you're always going to be the
other mhm but I think that you can get
more direct
response and that blunt energy of an
actual response rather than a polite
response yeah so just for people who
might be interested so in Japan they've
got this expression so I feel this in
Japan too which is a real bummer for me
me because when I was 15
as oh man I've studied so much Japanese
and also just living in Japan when I was
15 15y olds are kind of 15y olds in most
places right they're goofy they're loud
they're fun they're
open-minded and I felt welcomed with
open arms by and large by the kids
around me right because that kids are
kind of kids and they're curious too and
Shameless when I go back to Japan now
I'm still very close with my host family
30 years later or whatever still really
close with my host family and if they
introduce me to their friends
everything's great but as an adult going
to Japan there's a much stronger line
that I feel separates me as an other
it's very hard and there's an expression
there's like H and then so H is like I'm
very simplistically translating here but
it's like how you really feel and how
you really are and then tat is like what
you put in front mhm as your sort of M
forward- facing thing with someone else
and there's also something in Japanese
called tan which is like stranger
formality where you're polite but it's
there's a wall yeah right and my
experience just in a week I'm like what
do I know but my experience here and you
have to be careful if you're staying at
a hotel you can't be like oh people are
so friendly it's like well if you're
staying at a nice hotel of course
they're paid to be friendly so you got
to get outside but as I've been walking
around which we have been we have been
and people are friendly my feeling is
friendly maybe open is a better word
like could bit more open yeah they're
more open direct but it's direct
positive direct negative maybe like uh
I'm talking a lot but I'm excited to be
here when I was in high school and I met
my first Korean Koreans right like my
first interaction this was in this was
in New Hampshire that's right at St
Paul's yeah and nicest guy
until they flipped until that switch
flipped and their eyes got really big
and the kage came on the
scene which is not something you see as
much in Japan like people people get
pissed everywhere but a wise man once
said to me that you know you go to Japan
and and a lot of people get drunk It's a
drinking culture but they like they get
drunk and then they tend to like people
fall sleep like on the subway and so on
you don't see a lot of fights but maybe
that's different in Korea it's just a
different vibe I think that might be
part of the exports right there's K
Beauty k- Pop K dramas and there's K
raage I don't
know just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
wealth front there is a lot happening in
the US and Global economies right now a
lot that's an understatement are we in a
recession is it a bare Market what's
going to happen with inflation so many
questions so few answers I can't tell
the future nobody can but I can tell you
about a great place to earn more on your
savings and that's wealthfront
wealthfront is an app that helps you
save and invest your money and right now
you can earn 5% apy that's the annual
percentage yield with the wealthfront
cash account that's more than 10 times
more interest than if you left your
money in a savings account at the
average Bank according to fdic.gov so
why wait earn 5% on your cash today plus
it's up to $8 million in FDIC insurance
through partner Banks and when you open
an account today you'll get an extra $50
bonus with a deposit of $500 or more
there are already nearly half a million
people using wealthfront to save more
earn more and build long-term wealth so
why wait visit wealthfront.com to get
started that's wealthfront.com
this was a paid endorsement by
wealthfront so I want to go back to
natsukashi okay let's do it that is a
beautiful word m with a beautiful
meaning meaning incredible mhm when I
first heard it I think it was yeah my
wife who had lived in Japan for 10 years
she had used it with a friend and she
had explained it to me and I was like
that's so idealistic and just lovely
right but I was like there's no such
thing in Kar the experience of the Karem
people you know it has not been an
independent and whole country since 1905
it is divided since the Korean War and
there's a lot of pain and struggle that
happens with families divided by North
and South the side note we put this in
the show notes you sent me some YouTube
videos yeah which were old broadcasts a
family is being
reunited that [__] messed me up not
reunited reunited for like an hour an
hour and then they're separated again
and I'm not Korean I don't have the
background but just the holy [__] the
the emotion and the facial
expressions I was tearing up just
watching it's brutal it's it's not
relief of trauma it's new trauma on top
of long-standing trauma yeah what we're
talking about is you'll put it in put in
the show notes but the North and South
Korean governments had at certain times
when they get along they'll try to do
some great like Olive Branch moves to
reunite families and they had the the TV
station film it and they set up a whole
area and they brought buses down and it
turned out to be not cathartic at all
but reopening pain one of the things I
noticed was in the notes I guess it was
in text on one of the YouTube videos
that you sent me it indicated that
initially this television special was
supposed to be 45 minutes long but there
was such an outpouring there were like
100,000 plus people who came and stood
in front of various government offices
and stationed out trying to petition to
be part of this program that ended up
lasting I don't think I'm getting this
wrong I think it was like 100 plus days
that it kept going so first off this is
the last of the divided countries by
Western capitalism and Eastern communism
so Germany they've sorted it out Vietnam
they've sorted it out at this point
North Korea and South Korea is the last
sort of evidence of the really like
costic divisive Cold War mhm and so
there are families it's not two
different people mhm right it's not by
religion which we see a lot of today
unfortunately MH it's the same people
and the same families that are split and
torn from each other so imagine if you
have an opportunity to be reunited for
an hour and then separated
hour God so is that cathartic or is that
actually more trauma right yeah and so I
remember watching this as a child I was
in LA and my parents were watching it La
had a big enough korean-american
Community where you had Korean TV you
had a channel I remember watching it and
my parents like broke down crying and
you know for me it was like absorbing it
as a child but understanding it for the
first time like that history and what
that would feel like and I think that's
like a very like strong moving example
of how like Korean people feel in the
last 120 years they have not had their
own whole country and people it's north
and south MH before that it was Korean
War millions of Koreans died in that war
between Russia and China and the US and
the Battleground was their country their
homes their Farmland their cities so the
number of people that died in that War I
don't think people really talk about it
there's something about like 10 million
Chinese soldiers came across and at some
point or something like that they're
just numbers that people don't really
think we talk about World War II we talk
about Vietnam but there's not much about
the Korean War so and then the Korean
civilians and families that died right
before that they were liberated from
Japanese rule just like 5 years before
that and so 5 years before that they
spent 40 years 1905 to 1945 under
Japanese role and that was we've already
talked about that that was very
oppressive it was a forced assimilation
and there were a lot of deaths that
occurred as part of that an impression
and there are a lot of movies by the way
that detail this you know this is I
don't want to take us to off track
because I know we're headed towards hun
first yeah but what are the
main story lines that you see in movie
and dramas because these say a fair bit
yeah this is this is what we're talking
about which is in
language and in
stories you get a sense for the people
maybe without even meeting in real life
a person from that culture and
Society the tropes are the themes the
story lines that you hear in movies one
is about North South Korea there's
literally romcoms about it there's
action thrillers about it spy Thrillers
there's historical film you know
detailing in a biopic something that
happened in the past there's every kind
of
genre but applied towards the North
South Korea history and conflict another
one is the class struggle mhm you've
probably seen parasite which obviously
won an Academy Award and was seen
globally but that is director bong bong
Jun Hall is one of the greatest Korean
directors of all time a lot of his films
are very intense psychological thrillers
paris's pretty a lot of them you might
look at it and say oh this one's like a
murder mystery this one's a a
psychological Thriller this one is
something else but if you look at a lot
of his movies it's about class struggle
and does that mean put in another way
sort of lack of upward Mobility it's
about the wealthy and the entitled and
their mistreatment of the poor working
class that are immobile but also there's
complexity it's not just good versus
evil in that
dichotomy both sides in those character
sets are doing weird crazy off-putting
things to each other right and so that's
why I think Korean movies are are really
like well embraced because they don't
follow a formula they're nuanced it's
like swimming in an ocean of gray yeah
it's not it's like swimming in the human
mind mhm where there's nothing tot pure
and it's not a Marvel movie right and
it's it's not a sort of like uh it comes
to a conclusion act one act two act
three and now I feel good and actually
one of the things I would say
consistently about Korean film is that
it's both and this is a conflict that
can exist together at the same time it's
both
entertaining and moving and inspiring
and you can also walk out feeling
terrible you can walk out feeling
confused and like you need to go outside
and get breath of fresh air sit down if
you're a smoker you probably need a
cigarette if you're not a smoker you
probably need to take a walk and listen
to some happy music the intensity of
Korean film then is also balanced with
this polar opposite of these crazy
romcoms that are so sugary and sacarin
but funny MH and that's really creating
culture right it's this crazy full of
friction
opposites that you didn't think would
coexist in one culture cuz I think
people westerners outside ERS look at
Japan and they say this is ideal culture
this is ideal Society this is Utopia
almost to a lot of westerners everything
is clean everyone is polite everything
is in its right place and they do things
like take Italian pizza and actually
make it better right they take Fried
Chicken oh my God Steve has seen me eat
so much Fried Chicken here Korean Fried
Chicken it's the true KFC oh my God the
um so good Korean culture I think when
westerners or Outsiders come and and
they actually experience it and they see
it in movies and K-pop and they come
here and and what they see is something
that's a lot more realistic and nuanced
mhm well we went to have fried chicken
but not heavily breaded fried chicken
rather very lightly fried and that's the
original that's the OG Fried Chicken the
OG Fried Chicken we also had some ugly
potatoes as written on the menu ugly
potatoes they're basically tater tots
and you mentioned to me that the woman
who's running the show that day very
smart really had her operator hat on
very calm most likely let's just say the
daughter of the owner or somebody who
would hand it down but she may end up
working there for the rest of her life
or working career and that's a lot of
the stuff that's invisible if you're
only here for a brief time this class
struggle
is this is the theme of so many movies
books TV series it's the suffering and
struggle to move out of their condition
and that society and the upward crust of
society won't allow it and this tension
is in music it's in movies it's in
literature it's in TV shows it's all
around and you might say oh no it's
around every country sure it is but it's
really strong and consistent in Korean
movies and literature parasite is an
example of that you look at bongjun Ho's
all of his films they're all very
different some feel like a horror
Thriller some feel like a psycho
thriller another one feels almost like
comedic sci-fi fantasy like the host if
you see his like original film it's like
a giant monster moving around soul and
killing people but if you know from a
western mindset you're like what is
going on this is almost silly but it's
actually if you look at everything
that's happening it's talking about
class struggle this is part of what
Korea has been since the very beginning
of like its own sort of political
self-governance post Korean war is the
populism here you saw that in the
demonstrations it's a demonstration
activist society and it's constantly
battling with the fact that there are
very large companies that own so much of
the economy and your
success to raise a family and to have a
nice apartment and to put your kids in
Great Schools and things like that all
reside on whether or not you can get a
job and keep it at these large companies
CH yeah so they call them chbl outside
but the employees of those chibbles will
always call themselves conglomerates so
you got to you got to be careful right
yeah and I mean this is I'm sure they're
different but reminiscent of Japan with
like Sony Mitsubishi Etc but I think
there's more control mhm of the economy
from the conglomerates in Korea I'll
just sort of try to it back things that
I think you've said to me then you can
fact check or expand and then we will
eventually get to Han cuz I yeah yeah we
should do that but a couple of things
that struck me is super interesting one
is that these tboard I guess the
equivalent in Japanese would be kadat
yeah which is sort of like a chain of
related companies right AKA conglomerate
that here they are publicly traded but
they float a very small percentage of
the shares so they're kind of like the
Mars company in the US in the sense that
like they're privately held well not
privately held but they're they're still
family which is mindblowing to think
about just given the size of these
things secondly that and we didn't cover
this yet but the Broadband penetration
and the technological access here is
such in part it seems like because these
large conglomerates will coordinate with
the government to focus on yeah say one
or two things for five years 10 years
and they act in this concerted way which
would have to contribute to how Korea
punches above its weight class right
because what's I mean I don't know the
population of Korea but it's not a huge
place you know it's under 50 million
people it's nuts I mean to think
about what Korea has done on the global
stage and continues to do and will do
with that population it's kind of I mean
it is incredible that's the I don't want
to say the underbelly or the dark side
but it it is really the trade-off of
having on one side a very optimistic and
Progressive growth mindset for the
economy and society which is
pound-for-pound per capita probably the
most Innovative high growth in terms of
GDP country in the history of the planet
in the last 50 years I mean it is a
leader in Wireless technology is a
leader in chip manufacturing it's a
leader in heavy Industrials steel and
it's also now a leader in entertainment
Med media fashion beauty industry so
it's doing a lot it's accomplishing a
lot great the other side of that is that
there's still a class divide there's not
a lot of upper mobility and that's
changing for sure but it's still very
much and you see this in the stories
that are told these stories are told and
they're popular not because they don't
exist it's because that people feel that
they empathize with that they feel that
in their bones that this is their
condition in their life so the populism
here is different than in the US the
political Spectrum actually is different
there's not a left versus right in the
way that we think about it in the US
though the US is turning more into Korea
style of politics well we'll leave it at
that cuz I don't like politics but I am
recognizing this which is that the
populism here is about class struggle
and about workers rights and about
having a little bit more of a flattening
out so that people have opportunities to
be upwardly mobile the thing that you're
seeing today in film the thing that
makes parasite become a global
phenomenon and win Oscars is that story
it's a great film buin ho is a great
Storyteller and
cinematographer but it is the writing
and the acting you can take that story
as different as it is in it's a Korean
family two Korean
families basically fighting with each
other for the entirety of the film and
quiet and sometimes loud ways but you
empathize with both and you're critical
of both there's not a good versus bad
there's no hero versus villain and you
take that out into the US you take that
out into Europe you take that out into
any country it it
resonates it's Universal now it's
Universal and the writing is good and
the cinematography is great and what I
did not realize is this kwave is not
entirely an accident it's not like
people just threw a bunch of things
at random times independently into the
works and then Korea landed on the
global stage with entertainment there
seems to be a lot more to it and I would
expect though that many people listening
to this there's not really though a lot
of people listening to this are probably
if they're like oh Korea they're
listening to this because they saw
parasite or they're like why is K-pop so
big what the hell happened in the last
few years what is going on none of my
friends speak Korean why are they
listening how can they listen to keep
what is going on why is black pink on
like all over the place why is black
pink at Coachella yeah what is what the
hell is going on and then you have also
these streaming shows on Netflix right
yeah squid game you've got the I can't
remember I can never remember the name
these jacked men and women just physical
100 physical 100 right it's like
American Gladiators but elimination
challenge with Koreans it's amazing so
what is going on when I watched this doc
I was like oh wait a minute but behind
the scenes there is a lot of very clever
strategy look at squid game mhm class
struggle right but in
this intense crazy dystopian game makes
Hungry Games look like like a kid show
it really does I I remember watching
Hunger Games I hadn't seen it actually
until very recently and I was like oh
this is kind of boring yeah let me put
it this way if you were to take all of
these stories mhm and you were to look
at them as these are commercial
activities where you want the audience
to engage with it and to pay for tickets
right where does it come from who is
producing and paying for that the money
is coming the capital is coming from the
jevils the conglomerates M the
production companies behind K-pop
they're all publicly traded companies MH
the movie studios the production
companies the labels they're all huge
businesses worth billions of dollars so
also bit a lot government support right
yeah so originally in the 1980s Venture
Capital which is the industry I'm in and
your familiar with to as an angel
investor in the US venture capital is
focused on technology maybe biotech but
mostly technology software Venture
Capital started out as a government
supported industry focused in not only
on technology but mainly on media
entertainment movies you're talking
about in the US no or in Kore in Korea
and so K-pop and Korean movies and all
of this it's not controlled by the
government or supported by the
government today directly and often
times the sensors are coming down on
things and it's lightened up but you
used to not see like you know people
kissing in movies the Korean sensors
were pretty strong just like the
Japanese sensors yeah the Japanese
sensors are strong although anything
goes in the comic books yeah yeah we're
talking about National broadcast
National broadcast is different but the
the what you see as the kwave today a
lot of it came originally from the
Korean Venture Capital industry which
was supported by the government and
funded largely by the government it was
initially focused in on what we would
call now today soft power now look
there's a Korean semiconductor chip
industry and and whole bunch of
Technology areas that are now excelling
well but that was not the main focus or
the main success area for Venture
Capital so it's really interesting now
it's probably problematic for a lot of
uh a lot of uh politicians to see a lot
of this stuff depending upon what side
of the spectrum you're on on the
partisan side but I think that that's
what's has has resonated is that it
feels like the most irreverent and
authentic and weird sometimes crazy but
really like raw and Powerful movies out
there and TV series and it's very
different from any other formulaic
tropes that you see out there like
sometimes Korean movies take twists and
turns they'll start out like a romcom
and then turns into a zombie Thriller
parasite did that then ends up in like a
political thriller mode and you're sort
of confused like old boy is like the
probably the most famous movie before
parasite mhm and no one leaves watching
that movie saying it was bad you say it
was intense and it was incredible but
you also say I felt sick to my stomach I
think that's the value that that Korean
soft power starts spring so the movies
are easier for me to wrap my head around
than say K-pop right cuz there's good
music all over the world and they're
entertainers and boy bands and girl
bands in a lot of places most people
outside of Korea do not speak Korean
well hey like sometimes I'm in Hawaii or
I'm in La m in a um Hispanic
neighborhood and I will see posters of
BTS up on the walls and there's a whole
learning as a group yeah there's a whole
group of younger people in the US in
Latin America in Europe that are
following their favorite band which is
BTS or black paint oh I get it I'm just
wondering and learning Korean language
I'm wondering how that happened and is
this like Beanie Babies okay it's going
to like burn twice as hot and flame out
yeah or is there sort of more to the
story I think it's here to stay and I
think it's tied in with why anime
Japanese anime is ALS Al very globally
popular mhm which is it feels like a
fantasy world that is an escape from
their current world and that they can
aspire to so it's like you see in the
hip-hop community in the US they love
Naruto yeah I mean their hats their
shirts you think about how many hip-hop
groups would include things from like
Chinese kung fu movies and there's
always been this Wang Clan there's
always been this crossover of culture
from Asia on that level and it's been a
little bit more like let's take the
caricature of it or the themes of it and
let's include it but now it's become
part of like Global pop culture mhm the
K-pop stuff is really interesting
because they actually copied American
pop boy bands and girl bands yeah back
street boys but they just took it to the
next level the way like Japanese say
we're going to do French food or Italian
pizza and we're just going to take it to
the next level Hy di it in right we're
going to take American Automobile
engineering culture and we're going to
we're going to use like a Kaizen
approach and make more reliable cars
faster crazy story on that I think it
was Edward Deming who had something like
scientific manufacturing Scientific
Management this American
efficiency social scientist who was
basically ignored in the US was then
embraced by Japan and led to like the
Toyota Way C and stuff it's wild but to
your point Japan and it seems like as
you're describing it Korea really good
at like taking something that's good and
being like okay we're going to sort of
like spinal tap right like when we
really need actually turn it to
11 that's a good way to put it turn it
to 11 so on that front the formula of
the pop band was taken and it was turned
into a boot camp where there were
auditions and you would be trained and
you would learn how to dance you would
learn how to sing you would be assigned
a role as if you were in a military
outfit of some sort and you're the
rapper you're the lead singer you're
you're more of a dancer and so there's a
whole formula and
institutionalization that happened
around pop culture that Koreans really
took on right I'm connecting something
that I've never connected before tell me
if this is totally off base but you're
talking about class struggle and lack of
upward Mobility okay if you go to the US
like how many people are aspiring to be
in a boy or girl band not many
furthermore there isn't really there's
not much of like a discovery
mechanism or talent development program
for that I mean sure you can go to La
and and there are people who put these
bands together but in Korea you've got
these like Dance Training Studios where
people pay money yeah and basically
create their own like American Idol
vetting system yeah and then the Scouts
can pick from the yeah cream of the crop
right if you take that in it's like an
industrialization mhm of this very like
creative artistic culture that we rever
the authenticity of that in the US like
the unknown musician that rises up and
you love that right you love that
authentic story in Korea that's not
really a thing because K-pop it's pop
yeah it's manufactured now it doesn't
mean it's not good it just means that
they've been put through boot camp they
have coaches for every single aspect of
what they are supposed to be doing as
this admir and life too yeah everything
is very controlled now then you look at
the film industry I think it's quite
different MH film industry is much more
about a real look at a lot of things
that are not pristine and Polished in
society so you have K-pop which is deals
utopian sometimes a little plastic and
then you have these films that are
talking about North and South Korea
you're talking about Colonial history
between Japan and in Korea and you're
talking about class struggle internally
in Korea you're talking about the mental
health issues you're talking about all
of these much darker and much more real
and raw topics and so it's odd that
included in this picture of Korean soft
power is this very polished and
industrialized pop culture and then this
very intense and raw entertainment
culture on movies yeah you get the polar
extremes just because I've teased it so
much what is Han just like natsukashi is
quite Japanese super Japanese for
Koreans Han is probably the most talked
about recent Collective trait of Koreans
that Koreans talk about but then now
people outside are talking about and
what it essentially boils down to is
this idea of this Collective
suffering that the Korean people have
through history
and manifests in this sort of it's very
complicated feeling of we are suffering
and we share that pain with each other m
is not always a negative it can
sometimes drive
us to express
ourselves in strong ways it can drive us
to suffer together collectively so
collectivism is a very Asian thing yeah
and Independence is something that we
Revere in the
US that collectivism in Korea is han han
and is it generally you mentioned suff
Frank there are a lot of different
descriptions of this I was doing a
little bit of reading it's really hard
to explain in English actually it seems
very hard is it a type of so sadness
would be a component of that yeah and
also anger and Ang I was talking to
David Chang from muku he's old friend
and he asked me about Travis kic he had
never met him and he said you knew him
he seems like he has a lot of
Han and I said yeah he's intense and it
Expresses in in a drive to succeed right
and obviously we all know that story but
for Koreans Han can be a drive to do
great things to bond together to
understand each other to empathize but
it can also just be like you said the
anger and the the kage that you're
talking about which channeled correctly
allows you to build an entire industry
yeah and succeed on the global level to
create what is it chips on the shoulder
make chips in the pocket pop culture
phenomenons that win Grammys and that
movies that win Oscars and light up the
world to what's happening in this little
country that used to be a poor
developing country that was broken after
colonization and a war where does that
come from and so I think a lot of
Koreans romantically will describe it as
like we have this Han that drives us but
it's not perfect it's not always
positive it can just result in chaos and
destruction too but it's this thing that
feels very real and I think that's what
you're seeing in like Korean movies
that's what you're seeing in Industries
the positive energy that can come out of
it not just the negative energy so it's
very complicated but Jung mhm and these
are like very simple Chinese characters
and Korean characters so I wonder what
the I don't know the Hun for any of this
so Jung is is this connection or
affection this bond that you feel mhm
and so a lot of people will say that
they don't have Jung with someone or
that a person does not have Jung this is
a much more like bonding affectionate
thing and it's a very simple word but
means a lot mhm yeah Jung is also a
complicated thing too it's hard to
describe without using a lot of words
and adjectives and feelings and emotions
in English but when you say that that in
Korean it's very simple tell it means a
thing that isn't translatable mhm and
then if I were to take two words that
would describe Korean people and again
I'm not Korean I'm Korean American I'm
goo so I'm somewhat inside but somewhat
outside and so I can compare it to how
we are in America or other countries and
Han and Jong would pretty much
cover what what is nuni so nuni I mean
you know about k Bobby H you had him on
the show I did a friend of mine as well
great conversation he really got it
right which is it's reading the room but
nuni is like noon is your eyes yeah and
it's the ability to
see what's really going on reading
between the lines or reading the room MH
and this is really
important this is not a like happy
positive thing this is again a defensive
inquisitive analytical mhm skill right
Discerning Eye yeah it's very critical
yeah critical eye yeah there are things
that come up when you talk about people
and you talk about your connection with
them and so say if I come in and kind of
bluntly or obtusely am rude in a group I
walk into a dinner or a room I change
the topic really
obtrusively right like he just like
didn't read the room just kind of came
in like a
the Yeah Yeah there there isn't Lun and
then um you know with Han that's
something that I actually have not heard
a lot of Koreans talk about it I feel
like a lot of korean-americans and gilo
talk about it so it's an interesting
thing I think it's a more recent modern
yeah definition in term I don't think
it's like an old classic phrase or term
so my sense is anecdotally that it's
something that's been a little bit
now yeah and then also with Jong that's
something that my parents talk about a
lot yeah Jong and my parents don't talk
about Han it's like maybe the people
that really feel it don't want to talk
about it yeah totally and the people
that want to find some reason or some
rhyme to why they feel a certain way or
something is happening to them they'll
create a concept but I think it is very
interesting to look at those two
concepts Han and Jong M and then that'll
help you understand a lot in Korean
society and it helps me a lot actually
yeah I'll give you one one example if
you're a visitor to Korea there's a host
mentality in Japanese called otanashi
mhm in Korean there's a concept of
you're my sunim my guest and it's very
strong very similar to Japanese right
they want to
exceed in treating you well they want to
give you food they want to take care of
you you they want to do that they want
to create this concept of Jong not to
create the concept but to have Jong with
you and that would be the ideal cuz
Koreans most Koreans not all maybe but
Koreans want to have that connection
that deep connection they want to drink
with you they want to stay out late with
you they want to wrestle with you they
want to argue with you they want to put
their arms around your shoulder and sing
a song after like Downing some Soju
right they want to feel that like real
visceral connection with you and people
often I don't really enjoy it but people
often in business even in technology
which is somewhat of a more cerebral
industry they want to go out late and
have drinks until 5: 6:00 in the morning
and in the US we're like hey this is
just way too much like this is bedtime
they want to do that to know that they
have a bond with you they want to create
that somewhat like
abruptly right but you see that yeah I'm
trying to find the character for Jung
it's really bothering me that I oh wait
wait okay Jung is Jung is good Jung is
positive Jung is optimistic yeah warm
feeling of attachment yeah Han not so
much yeah Jong you see that character
the Chinese character in pretty sure in
Concepts like sympathy those types of
sort of feeling emotive MH Concepts
empathy
sympathy affection Bonds in every movie
in every TV
series they're moving in and out of Han
and
Jung in the narrative in the
storytelling and that's I think if you
were to whittle it down if you had to
really simplify and reduce it to
something very like at root level I
think it would be that Koreans are
moving between Jung and Han in their
storytelling in their life their
business there is a moment with probably
with your friends in high school where
it's all happy and positive then maybe
after a critical moment or an emotional
thing or maybe if you guys were drinking
beers at night as teenagers where it
flipped yeah usually I could tell if the
eyes got really big I'll be like oh oh
boy here we go I'm red yeah yeah red
face big eyes I'm like oh oh oh oh I
think we're getting into Hulk smash
there's energy energy frequency has
changed but yeah so that I mean I wanted
a yeah that's that's what I would think
about when I think about like how to
whittle it down to something basic
before coming to Korea was trying to do
a bit of reading I didn't want to do too
much reading people have asked me a lot
what did you expect and I'm like I
didn't expect anything I tried to come
in as blank as possible but I did a
little bit of reading I didn't want to
come in completely ignorant and it seems
like the government has either earmarked
or committed maybe already spent who
knows something like $2 200 billion
maybe those are tax incentives I have no
idea but $200 billion US for increasing
birth rate so what is the I guess status
of birth rate
in Korea in this case South Korea and
why is it so low why would you explain
that so first off the countries around
the world have a relatively low birth
rate reproductive rate Germany Japan
even right now China is having that
problem so there's that but what I think
is happening in Korea is that this class
divide the
economic condition in Korea is that the
halves have a lot and the have kns it's
hard for them to move up it is very
expensive it is a high cost of living in
in so maybe not in the countryside but
everyone wants to live in the city to
get an
apartment you know in the US you put
down maybe a month two months maybe 3
months of deposit and then you can get a
pretty nice apartment if you have a job
in Korea you have to put down a year or
two of your rent my God as a deposit and
what you get is maybe a one-bedroom
apartment and one of the these large
concrete highrises that you see just
stacked around so mhm and so to start a
family is quite expensive yeah so
there's that cost of living to start a
family I don't know if you have an
answer to this but why so much deposit
why a year or two of deposit the
consumer credit
culture is not in good shape it's never
been in good shape in in Korea as long
as I've been I'm laughing because we had
to take a pause earlier CU I got a phone
call from the hotel who was like you've
exceeded your incidentals can you come
down and make your deposit I'm like you
have my credit card card they don't
trust you the way this the way this
works is I charge stuff and then I pay
at the end and they're like no you have
to come down and put down a further
deposit I'm like okay all right fine
so financial crisis 1997
98 because of Thailand and Japan went
down Korea went down right M and this is
a good example actually of Han and Jang
together yeah I'm trying to make connect
Dots here right to simplify for the the
audience but there was a austerity
program mhm Korean government went out
through media and said we need every
citizen of the country to take their
personal
jewelry and contribute it to the
National cause to the IMF austerity
program that was laid upon them to get
bailed out essentially and people
donated their jewelry they melted it
down for the sake of the greater good
the common Collective good so wild just
to think about how poorly that would go
down in the US would not go down at all
no of course like we can't even do that
with guns right it's like there's no
sense of gun control imagine now take
all of your
valuables melt it down but the other
side of that is that there is a
speculative gambling culture in
investments in real estate and stocks
bonds real estate that was so bad in
Korea that people were taking out credit
cards at like
30% interest rates and buying consumer
goods it's still happening
today the Korean consumer luxury Market
is the per capita highest Market on the
planet really that's why you see all of
these European luxury Brands every
single mall they have huge stores luxury
brands have been focused in on marketing
to Koreans for now 5 10 years there's
this consumer goods culture here this
consumerism materialism that is
problematic because it's a lot of it is
on borrowed borrowed money mhm and so in
the '90s they had this problem the
subprime credit market for consumers
they even stopped derivatives trading in
Korea because of it because people were
getting so upside down
on their investment speculation there is
a speculative almost gambling problem in
Investments it got to the point where
the leftwing government that was in
power in the last Administration during
covid a lot of wealthy people were
buying properties and they limited
people from buying more than one second
property so that you can buy a third can
you imagine that in the US again
something that would never happen in the
US so there is this sense of like you
know one there's a class
divide and it's very expensive it's a
High Cost of Living to start a family
and it's also very hard to move up that
so why even go
there my other theory on this is that
not only is it expensive but social
values are changing women have largely
been unable to enter in the professional
workplace but that is changing and
that's a good thing they can go work at
a company and rise up and become an
executive so careers are now not just
Service employee careers but actual
executive careers company careers
corporate careers in these conglomerates
are now possible and so as that shifts
to be more balanced and fair there's
less young couples getting married early
and having babies so I think there's two
things there that I would I would say
and I see that among like extended
family members friends is a very
expensive proposition because you want
them in the best schools you're going to
put them in the baseball hug one you're
going to put them in the swimming hug
one the math hug one the piano lessons
like all of that from 300 p.m. all the
way to 9:00 p.m. yeah so you are
spending a lot of money per year for
each child because you want them to have
the very best mhm and in Korea the
competitiveness around this is
incredible yeah if you're not putting
them in the hug one who are you as a
parent and that's incredible pressure
and that's incredible like exorbitant
cost for someone who is not upwardly
mobile does not have an opportunity to
have stock in a company and have it exit
like we love in Silicon Valley we put
out stock options and Equity as like the
carrot of Entrepreneurship and
risk they don't have that here and it's
changing there are more and more
startups there are unicorns that are
coming out of Korea coupang toss there's
a lot of consumer marketplaces and
fintech companies it's becoming sort of
a Silicon Valley of Korea and it's
exceeding the speed in in Japan it's not
quite what China is China's very very
Advanced and forward there but Korea is
finally having a startup culture where
risk is appreciated and admired and
rewarded in some cases but outside of
that it is very expensive and is very
difficult
and a lot of young couples may not want
to get married right away they may want
to make their way in their career so I
think it is a problem I mean we all know
the economics around population decline
M that hurts GDP it correlates it's
causal too but at least it correlates we
can agree on that so I think it is a
real problem I don't know how it's
solved not that I've thought a lot about
it or someone's asked me to solve it can
you imagine a small country like this
shrinking yeah and what that does does
again to all these things so and a lot
of people want to move out they want to
go so my family and everyone Elsa's
family everyone who moved to the
US I would say 99% of them moved for a
better life to go to America and to be
able to live a better life and provide
just a higher quality education and
lifestyle for their families because it
was hard in Korea in the 60s 70s even
80s so if people are moving out to find
that upward Mobility to do better for
their families and then here you're
somewhat still confined that's a tough
thing and there's one last thing that is
really challenging about Korea it's
there's a civil service
examination that you take to get into
that score really decides whether or not
you get into a top university I see
that's the equivalent of an entrance
exam but it's more than that it's like
you can not do well in the SAT but you
have a good GPA yeah you interview well
then you have all these tiers of Junior
College fouryear
college I League State schools you have
a lot of options liberal arts colleges
whatever whatever you're looking for
here you're a top college or you're
not and if you do not go to college it
is highly unlikely that you will have
the ability to provide for a family a
large family well in a healthy way
you're definitely not going to all these
hug ones and things like that mhm so
you're right in saying that K-pop and
K-pop is like us is like Pro Sports you
know that's the way that's the side
route out and I think K-pop and movies
and entertainment and gaming Esports is
huge here we saw as they were setting up
League of Legends uh stages downstairs
yeah enormous I mean there it's just
it's like an
entire playing field full of people down
there engaging with League of Legends
and those PC bungs right playing there
was a guy walking around with a huge
sword shirtless and it was snowing that
is
dedication let's switch gears to a
little bit more about like what's
happening in soft power let's do it what
was your take on all of this
entertainment
media the beauty industry this kwave
what was your opinion of it before
coming here I've been paying for close
attention to it for the last few years
because I'm
always
curious to distinguish between Trends
and feds right I brought up beanie
babies not to throw beanie babies under
the bus but there are certain
things that become fashionable because
maybe a handful of celebrities are using
X Fillin the blank like Ugg boots has
been had many lives it's like a phoenix
or I could certainly list many many
different things but
but how do you distinguish between that
and not to get too financy but like a
secular Tailwind with some type of trend
that is inevitable right like
penetration of broadband and
smartphones and also trying to identify
the fly wheels at play or
the elements that contribute to momentum
so for instance if you look at
podcasting and for lot of people who are
have have not had the engagement that
I've had for 10 plus years now or no
it's not 10 plus years but as a listener
10 plus years but as a producer as a
producer of podcast going to be 10 years
next April it seems like podcasts went
from kind of nothing to everywhere is
the perception for someone who's only
engaging with it now but they heard
about podcast they like wow how did it
become that everyone is now on a podcast
with a podcast talking about podcasts
seems like 5 years ago there was nothing
well there was something 5 years ago
just like there was was K-pop 5 years
ago but it suddenly seems like there's
surround sound stereo where it's on
magazine covers and it's online
everywhere and there's news and your
friends are talking about it and there
documentaries and sometimes that comes
together as an emergent property of a
bunch
of unrelated events but sometimes
there's orchestration and architecture
behind it or there's an example of a
standout success so for instance in the
case of podcasting seral was that
serial became a phenomenon it was the
show that everybody had to listen to and
it gripped maybe not the entire nation
but kind of
the New York
Literati crowd and since the New York
Literati run the Mast heads of these
huge media Outlets it gave the
impression of Serial being huge which it
was it was huge yeah and people were
like podcast how do I even listen to a
podcast it introduced people to the
medium exactly it introduced people to
the medium introduced them to
platforms and looking at this explosion
of Korean media I'm like okay where did
this start what set the snowball in
motion and I haven't figured it out I
have not although certainly parasite was
a huge that was huge but I'm like that
can't be I feel like that's the result
of some preceding things that I have
missed yes right but I just haven't
known how to dissect it so I'm like okay
well let me keep an eye on things and
then I see squid game okay so squid game
squid game squid games like always mess
up if it's singular or plural but anyway
you see that explod I'm like okay that's
interesting based on that success I
would imagine Netflix because this seems
to be what Netflix does to be like let
us double down on whatever this is
algorithmically what makes this show
this show big part of it is Korea it
changed Netflix yeah their whole
International strategy was a good
strategy it was very unique to them no
one else was doing Hulu Disney they're
not focusing on International Netflix
was the only one when they launched in
Korean and Japan I was like great it'll
bring up subscriber numbers yeah but
then when it hit in Korea mhm they
increased the budgets many times over
because they saw that it was not only
the Korean market that loved this
programming but it was the global
markets it was the content the films and
the TV shows coming out of the market
and that they could distribute all
across the planet I once look at the
Netflix they were sort of carrying the
pollen of Korean culture M this pop
culture this media culture entertainment
and they accelerated it to a level where
it probably felt like a sudden overnight
thing but you're absolutely right it's
not only emergent but it was emergent
over the course of several decades
right and so it's emerging over the
course of several decades and then there
are these accelerants right like Co
almost certainly was an acceler you
people at home 100 watching Netflix
looking for something to bond over and
boom around the same time you've got a
bunch of this Korean stuff coming in
that's very high quality really
compelling and it's new also people yeah
people are like what what is this right
like Americans reading
subtitles and uh and even though I've
never really been involved with film a
little bit with television I'm very
interested to see which dominoes tip
over a lot of other dominoes right and
how the macroeconomic stuff factors into
it geopolitics but it's more the
economic side so for instance seeing how
Film Production has changed both in
terms of funding for films but also Main
protagonists in the US where almost I'm
not going to say without exception but
if you look at a lot of the Blockbusters
whether it's the Impossible movies or
Marvel movies it's like they always want
to have a Chinese at least one Chinese
man character why because it is very
important that you get the Chinese
market super important finan right and
it almost feels like just jammed in
there though oh it's totally jammed in
there it's like what okay Victorian like
a biopic and there it's a Chinese guy
it's totally just like shoehorned in a
lot of the time but part of the reason I
paid so much attention to Korea is that
Korea is small yeah right so it's like
an export game the US is not looking for
like total addressable Market in Korea
it's the opposite which is a lot harder
to pull off as a smaller player and I've
been tracking it I've also been
impressed very impressed and this does
not get I don't think this gets enough
airtime so hopefully this podcast will
make people explore a bit like Korean
design mhm and aesthetic mhm is super
sharp and the best book design I want to
be fair there are a couple of really
good ones in terms of Publishers who
have published my books in foreign
languages the Korean publisher maybe
Publishers for my books have done an
exceptional job with book
design and as you know and as we've been
discussing education import right
literacy very high voracious readers in
Korea also true with Germany it's
disproportionately the case where like
you look at how my books have performed
in Germany and it outperforms the UK
plus Australia plus like almost
everywhere outside of the US because the
culture itself values education and
reading but to your question about Korea
like K-pop I mean pop music in general
especially boy bands girl bands is not
really my Jem but as a study it's
interesting for me because I feel like
it could be anything I read a book on
Ryan a ages ago cuz I was like okay how
did Ryan a suddenly seemingly become
ubiquitous how did this happen because
if I can study that and I can study
what's happening with K-pop and then
create an entertainment maybe there's
something I can learn that will allow me
to as an investor predict this earlier
right where you have converging trends
that are coming for instance like
Shopify we were talking about Shopify
earlier today that was as far as I know
the first adviser to shop when they had
like 10 employees and it's like if you
just looked at Tech Trends if you were
able to bet on the right team in
e-commerce and setting up that kind of
backend Plumbing for websites to be able
to sell things it's
like this is a trend that is going to
continue doesn't seem to be any
reasonable possibility that could be
interrupted outside of like nuclear
Holocaust so let's find the right team
and that maybe in retrospect seems
obvious but so do a lot of great
companies but if you can kind of see
where things are converging Uber right
in our case would be another example of
that where it's like okay let's not look
at and this parallels to Korea where
it's like in the beginning and you
remember this I mean how many hundreds
of people said no to Uber right Uber
ended up on like Angel list early days
and like people are like what this is
ridiculous this is for black cars for
the 1centers in San Francisco's boo lame
Tech bro blah blah blah and a lot of the
professional investors who said no said
no because they were like well let's
look at the total addressable market for
people who are going to use black cars
look at what percentage Uber can yeah
manage to secure it's like no it's not
the right way to look at it it would be
like looking at parasite and these
various TV shows and being like all
right well what's the population of
Korea oh it's declining well what
percentage of Koreans can you get to
watch this it's like no no no you can
expand the market right right so I know
I'm Meandering a bit all over the place
but so one is like a predictive
mechanism like all right well can I see
things that two three five years from
now are going to be obvious but I'll
just like see it earlier because I've
learned to look for the precursors and
then secondly because I write because I
have a podcast coming up on my 10th
anniversary and I'm using that as an
opportunity to think about what's next
for me and generally after 5 to 10 years
of doing something it gets really if I
pick it correctly the game gets harder
often times I end up enjoying it less
even though I'm still enjoying the
podcast and I'm like all right what's
next for me in which case maybe there
are techniques maybe there are things I
can look for levers I can pull that
would allow me to also build momentum on
a micro level that I've seen at the
macro level say with this crean
entertainment stuff so yeah I've been
paying a lot of attention but I'll be
honest I don't know how to pay proper
attention because I don't think the way
to pay proper attention is to read the
mainstream us media coverage of the
kwave I don't think that's the right way
to do it no absolutely not right I'll
give a shout out to some books that have
been very helpful there's a great outfit
to guess a publishing company called
talk to me in Korean I've got talk to me
in Korean level one we got real life
Korean conversations for beginners I'm
hoping to improve my Korean enough that
eventually at some point I could
actually do some Korean language reading
on this stuff or listening I will say in
the week that we've been here I was
really honestly surprised at not only
your ability to read Korean hung
wherever we want but to also deliver it
and enunciate it in the right way and so
I was kind of surprised I mean we've
been friends for a long time and I've
seen you speak Japanese and Mandarin but
I was really surprised because I knew
you've never been here and never studied
any Korean language language and I
remember I asked you I said how long
have you been studying you're like 2
days so even as a longtime friend I was
very surprised so that's a skill that is
not only about finding a great method or
applying yourself but the fact that you
would insist to order by yourself and
you would have a conversation with
someone there's a a part of like
throwing yourself into the mix to be
able to do that so question back to you
on that cuz I admire that that's amazing
thank you like I've had to do that in
Beijing and Shanghai with mandarin
because I look
Asian I can pass a little bit more when
I'm speaking you know I'm like you know
I hung right and so and I'll get a
little bit of a pass right but you know
you're a white guy and you're coming in
here confident so I know that you've
learned a lot of Asian languages and
you're fluent in two of them mhm tell me
about what you were doing when you were
learning like how do you think about the
material mhm and how do you think about
your method on both those cuz I think
that's really interesting I I've never
seen someone do this with Korean this
fast and I've had a lot of people try so
I want to give a a heartfelt high five
and thank you to the Korean people first
because I will say part of the reason
I've been so excited to do it and then
I'll get into the method and what I'm
doing is people here are so supportive
of it they're surprised and the positive
feedback is great so which is not like
France it's not like France I mean there
are some great people in France but
they're less supportive in Japan they're
very supportive right like if you can
introduce yourself like oh you know oh
Jo Jo but I wasn't sure what to expect
here and it gives me the the impression
and I don't know if this is accurate but
it gives me the impression that a lot of
foreigners just don't try here because
people are like oh like if I order
sparkling water in Korean they're like
oh wow yeah so the the approach that
I've taken and part of the challenge in
learning any language is you don't know
which textbooks or sources are going to
be good now there are tools and full
disclosure like I invested in them very
in their series a but like dualingo has
become this incredible resource
worldwide so I did use some
Duolingo I then supplemented that I
wanted to look at methods that I had
applied to previous languages and there
are a few methods that offthe shelf
other people can use and then I have my
own kind of eclectic freestyle approach
that I use with most languages there is
a method called the Michelle Thomas
method m i c h l Thomas method and
Michelle Thomas way back in the day I
think he taught languages to Barbara
strian and all these celebrities he was
if I'm remembering correctly he either
born in Switzerland or Germany he was in
the military I believe he was Jewish
taught T himself a million different
languages and I think he was in
intelligence for a good period of time
and what I like about his method is that
it is for most people the opposite of
what they experienced in school that is
very unpleasant for most people who are
subjected to it most people who study
language in school they're like first of
all I'm never going to use what they're
teaching me second of all they're trying
to get me to read tables of
conjugations it's so foreign not just in
the language but just in the
format that a it's unpleasant B people
don't retain anything a lot of people
who are say American listening to this
will have in school been required to
study multiple years of Spanish and
nonetheless they basically don't speak
Spanish right they can ask where the
bathroom is or say good day that's about
it Michelle Thomas asks you to take no
notes whatsoever it is purely auditory
interesting and you listen to the
method no reading no reading zero
reading okay there are some shortcomings
associated with that which is why I've
added other things but with the Michelle
Thomas I started I read this cartoon
which was how to learn to read Korean in
15 minutes which is really well done and
I'll put this in the really well done
I'll put this in the show notes then I
watched a couple of YouTube videos on
how to read
Korean and just to get the reading up to
speed again in this particular case it's
not true for Chinese it's certainly
going to be harder for something like
Arabic Greek you can do it pretty easily
cilic so Russian you could also learn to
read and sound out in about an
hour once you have that your goal is to
get to the point where you can absorb
things ambiently by walking around and
seeing menus and so on on a trip like
this but with the Michelle Thomas method
it's similar to what some people will be
familiar with as the pimsler method
where it introduces
vocabulary and then it basic functions
almost like Anki there's an app called
Anki which means rote memorization in
Japanese funny enough or I think it was
super memo way back in the day which had
some type of I I want to say it was like
an algorithmically driven spaced
repetition system so when you're just
about to forget a word it prompts you to
recall it and it's very effective at
helping you to retain this material
because it'll introduce something like
Gill like to study and then they won't
use it for like 30 minutes and then
it'll be like I am going to study Korean
today and so you're using it in a
different way but the same you're using
it in a different context but taking the
same word that you're just about to
forget yeah and then it pops it back up
to the top in your short-term memory and
so you would
say and then later on it'll be like you
already learned how to say I studied
Korean today how would you say I studied
Korean yesterday but hajim I'm going to
work
today and then it'll be like all right
you learned how to say and I was very
impressed with the way they did it
Michelle Thomas was like the Michael
Jordan of language teaching So I
listened to his original recordings
before he died for Spanish German
Italian and he was can't tanous as [__]
which I loved like he would get all
pissed off at the students because the
format is somebody is teaching to other
students right and they're live like the
other students are screwing up and like
sometimes they get it right sometimes
they get it wrong and you're the third
student so you have to try to answer you
answer before the other students and
then the other students answer and I
listened to the Michelle Thomas original
recordings and I was very skeptical that
they could take his method and have
another teacher use it with students but
the way they did it in this Korean is
they had an american guy who lived in
Korea speaks Kore Korean and then they
had a native speaker and it was a
combination and I thought they did a
very nice job the one critique I would
have is that in the original
recordings Michelle Thomas would say
something like how do you say I want to
eat k in Spanish right and then it Go
Boop and there'd be a beep and that
meant You're supposed to reply there was
a space and then it would go back to the
recording and the other two students
would answer with the Korean you have to
hit pause a million times because if you
just hear the students repeat you're
training your recognition but not your
production so I was using the Michelle
thas method and I only got through four
or five of those before you arrived and
I knew I was going to be doing less
sitdown studying yeah yeah I mean you
really haven't had it any time I idea so
you're you're actually giving samples of
correct grammar Korean right now I'm
still impressed because you haven't
really had much time to do this no I
haven't had much time but I will say
also what I've tried very hard to do and
this is a question I get a lot from
folks there are many people who are
better at learning languages than I am
but because it's not my full-time thing
like there's some people who are online
and their brand is language learning
it's like okay well you better be better
than I am and you you have the space to
do that because it's your job and that's
not a swipe like there are some amazing
people out there who speak you know 10
plus languages and did it as adults it's
mindblowing the only way that I can
maintain my other languages is if I tie
them to the next language that I learn
so for instance I used Spanish to then
learn German by using one piece the
comic book One Piece has a gazillion
volumes so you can read it in Japanese
and then when I learned Spanish I had
the same volumes in Japanese and Spanish
so I try to read them in Spanish the
benefit being it's almost all dialogue
if I couldn't figure it out before I
went to the dictionary I would go back
to the Japanese version panel for panel
it's the same thing I be like oh okay
okay and then I'm tying the Japanese to
the Spanish and then when I learned
German a couple months later which I've
totally forgotten unfortunately German's
gone so sorry about that guys it's it's
to but I've forgotten it all then I used
the Spanish one piece to learn the
German one piece this is a Japanese
Manga comic book that is legendary it's
the highest grossing franchise out of
Japan as far as manga go above Dragon
Ball Z and all of those and with the
Korean
I knew reading was the key unlock
reading was was number one the second
piece was that I had to tie it to
something else I already knew and I did
that with Japanese and and Korean a lot
of strong similarities strong
similarities so for instance even though
they wouldn't admit it no exactly this
is where I have to be so careful because
now I'm coming here and Alex I can know
the history but I'm like [__] I don't
want to get I don't want to piss people
off you know what's really interesting
is a lot of Koreans speak Japanese yeah
yeah very well yeah you have a lot of
tarot card reading places here which I
did not expect at all and a lot of them
say that they can also do the readings
in Japanese I've seen a number of signs
that's probably because of there are a
lot of Japanese tourists oh for sure
yeah a lot of Japanese women mhm love
coming for tour guided trips in Korea
going to the
locations in the story line of Korean
dramas and movies dramas it's like the
Americans who go to
de brnik or wherever to see the Game of
Thrones places no it's a whole travel
tourist sector wow and it's not just
Japanese it's you know other Asian
groups and Europeans actually here's a
funny interesting fact someone from naor
which is one of the big public internet
companies here kind of like Yahoo or
Google side note if you think you're
going to use Google Maps here you're not
you're going to have to download
neighbor Maps yeah so the super app
thing is real here by the way what Elon
wants to do with Twitter has only been
done really in Asia and maybe Latin
America right yeah you're talking like a
WeChat type of thing you can do
everything in one up yeah so someone
from neor told me in a meeting that
K-pop is so big and all the different
like the digital artwork and media and
content and all the things that you can
buy and consume around that type of
artist I think about all the merch
digital merch said France is actually a
large Market than the domestic Market
wow by dollars and and I said are you
sure do you mean by some other metric
some other I said no by by gross dollars
we do better with all of the licensed
partnered content around K-pop bands and
artists in France than we do in Korea so
that might be just their business around
K-pop digital content but it is
interesting that Korea is almost wholly
across the board to your point about
Netflix to your point about what to
learn it is an export Society it is an
export
economy they are shipping things like
steel they are shipping things like
chips yeah Wireless smartphones MH
they're now starting to ship software in
marketplaces they're moving out and they
also in that other side of soft power
they're exporting movies
books TV series music Fashion Beauty
Korean beauty products are growing like
wildfire not only in the US where that's
understandable because you have a
diaspora korean-american group and
Asian-American but Europe where French
and swiss Beauty that's the stronghold
yeah of the eurocentric beauty concepts
of beauty Korean products are becoming
luxury products there next to the lvmh
and the the caring group products right
so I think if there's anything to learn
from that export mindset I mean you
mentioned about how you felt like the
book publishing and the design there's
bakeries that are and this is really
falling suit of what Japan did over the
last 40 or 50 years it was a contract
manufacturing economy that became an
original OEM design economy they
leveraged what they had learned and they
did it better like the story of Japanese
whiskey yeah is incredible right they
sent one guy to go learn from the
Masters in Scotland and he came back and
started Sor yeah right it's wild and I
think a lot of that was learned by
Koreans and they started learning that
in heavy industry the main street in
kangam is called okay so just it's quick
footnote for people so if you remember
the that's a another breakthrough moment
kind of like serial Gangam Style that
music video pass a billion views and
people are like what the hell is going
on Gung total breakthrough moment for
Korean
culture and gangnam is a neighborhood
yeah Gangnam
is the most modern District in so it's
the newest Modern area of Office
Buildings we went there the other day a
lot of LED walls and fancy stores things
like that it's the newsole Korea shifted
from an economy of contract
manufacturing Samsung was a contract
manufacture for Japanese companies
electronics companies as well as having
all these other businesses in the larger
conglomerate but in the beginning a lot
of this was shipping import export heavy
industry things like that mhm and then
there were contract manufacturers for
Sony Sony was originally a contract
manufacturer for American Consumer
Electronics companies so there was a
transition but there was a moment in
Korean history where the export of Labor
this skilled industrial labor was what
helped bring revenue and Country
alliances to Korea which is a very poor
country at the time so the main road in
Gangnam is called
teano and the reason why it's called
tahano is that Iran when it was a
capitalist liberal country mhm in the
70s and the 60s too
hired a lot of Korean Workforce so did
Saudi Arabia and other countries to come
be the skilled labor huh in other
countries like Koreans were the miners
in Germany they got exported there to be
the minors because no one and
domestically wanted to be a minor
because you had a higher likelihood of
death and faima so the reason why it's
called teano is that it's in tribute to
their friends in Iran who gave them all
this economic uplift through Labor and
revenue and they named it after tan wow
and so that's why it's called
Tano and if you look at like the history
of Korea it was we will export our men
and our women as nurses and our men as
hard labor in these industrial roles and
then it was shipping then it was steel
and then they moved up the pyramid in
terms of becoming a service economy into
a manufacturing economy M and then to a
knowledge workers service economy right
and they started creating original chip
designs working on
broadband and being the leaders in
Broadband both Wireless and fiber
Broadband I was speaking with one of the
leading Wireless Telos here and they're
not like AT&T and Verizon back home they
are like the big tech companies that
have software
he was telling me that singel and other
Regional wireless companies mobile
carriers in Asia often come to them to
ask them about the newest technology how
they should approach their own
strategies around this around LTE 5G and
now around AI mhm and so Wireless
telecom companies here are building
their own language
models yeah that's why you would never
expect AT&T and Verizon to go compete
with open AI yeah and so there is this
accelerated sense of we must achieve
something tomorrow because we're already
behind and that is a very Korean
mentality what we were talking about
with Han and Jang I'm going to try to
bring this all together in a theory in a
grand Theory but this Grand theory is
also that tomorrow is not guaranteed for
South Koreans there's a well understood
tension with North Korea that at any
moment this could all be over I don't
truly understand it cuz I'm an American
I live in California but my parents the
older generation they feel it they talk
about it they obsess over it if you look
at newscasts you look at books you look
at
YouTube this is like the Hot Topic what
to do about this how do we
reunify or do we not and I think because
tomorrow is not guaranteed they're
living in the moment to do exactly what
they want as fast as possible with an
impatience that expresses itself as so
industrious so productive look at them
cranking out such a small country
cranking out films that are winning a
can film festival the Palm Door there
Oscar is here you know largest the most
successful artist music artist in the
world most you know high growth cosmetic
Beauty Brands largest Mobile smartphone
manufacturer other than Apple why is
this coming from the small country my
opinion on this and people can disagree
and many many would is that they are
designed in their mindset and raised
with if you don't do it now you may
never have a chance to do it again later
and so they are living in the moment
knowing that 17 miles away are millions
of soldiers and artillery and missiles
pointed at them I'm glad you brought up
the 17 miles away cuz in most people's
mind at least I shouldn't say most what
a ridiculous statement in my mind and in
the minds of certainly many of my
friends Soul has this huge cosm palon
City M exists it is far away from North
Korea it is not far away it is right
there it's very close a frame it in
terms that people can understand it is
closer than San Francisco is to San
Jose that's 28 miles yeah substantially
closer and so this living in the moment
or achieving for just tomorrow mhm this
impatience yeah that to me me is this
Han that's looming in the background of
everyone's mind and this is angst about
upward mobility and being able to
achieve that pushes Kens out in the
diaspora to become gilo because they
can't do it here because the system
won't allow it it's kinetic and it's
sometimes ugly and painful but it's
kinetic and it's the craziest thing and
when people come here even me for me
like who understands this somewhat and I
come in as a half Insider half Outsider
I get the sense and it's very emotional
for me actually like in the US I feel
very stoic about all that's happening I
feel like I was raised in that but when
I come back here it's like I'm going
into this other dimension where everyone
here is moving twice as fast it's like
the feeling like when you go to New York
the physical kinetic aspect of what's
happening there you're like wow La
people are so moving so slowly
physically moving slowly yeah and in New
York you're like you feel tired after
like a couple days in Manhattan you come
to Korea I think only New Yorkers can
really understand living in Soul because
you have to move fast it's kinetic it is
hyper
kinetic and I think people should visit
man I really do I think people should
visit and learn some Korean it's such a
beautiful language the writing
especially if you've only ever read
romanized alphabet mhm what a fun thing
to stretch your brain and learn some
Korean hungo because it's so as you said
regular like once you have it you have
it it's not like English where you can
have fish like f is f i and then enough
is o f same sound o u g it's like oh my
God this language it's a mess it's a
complete mess and Korean is super
regular and what I would say also about
language just as an addendum to what
we're talking about is if you learn 10
sentences anybody can learn 10 sentences
anybody MH it will fundamentally change
your experience in a country full stop
people will respond to you differently
you will also be a better guest in that
country and it's fun and you can learn
10 senses it's not that hard and there's
going to be stuff for instance I love
sparkling water I know every day I'm
going to ask for sparkling water so it's
like T learn how to ask for sparkling
water and then like every time I get an
omelet it's like oh yeah there's no salt
and pepper why is there no salt and
pepper in this country and then I'm like
I know I'm going to have to ask for at
least salt it's like learn how to say
salt and and there are a couple of other
just fun tips for folks like you can
come up with a couple of because you're
going to be entertaining as a foreigner
trying to learn a foreign language like
Korean so you know learn a couple of
things that are like off menu CU like
where's the bathroom is on menu like
they would expect that something you
would learn well asking for food I mean
so what's been your thought about Korean
food so far I mean you've had Korean
food in the US or you know that version
of it so what do you think so far oh man
Korean food is incredible let's give a
couple just on the language thing I'll
wrap it up real fast which is like learn
a couple of phrases that are kind of
funny so for instance in almost any
language you can learn to say something
like long time no see which by the way
in English is borrowed directly from
Chinese long time no see but you can you
know like in Japanese or here like like
use a really polite form and there
people wow that was good oh thanks and
people are like what like I'm like I'm
just kidding it's not that long and
people get a good laugh out of it so so
you can learn a couple of things like
that or like you know CH like just like
like no rush take it easy like do it
slowly so learn a couple of things like
that and you'll just have a better time
Korean food is [__] amazing it's so
good it's so good and I did have a funny
experience I'll be honest I have not had
much cream barbecue but I wanted to of
course have cream barbecue and went out
to cream barbecue and there were a bunch
of side dishes and I started like eating
the salad because it looked like an
appetizer the guys were like uh that's
not an appetizer that's a side dish that
you eat when the beef comes out I like
oh okay great so the beef comes out and
number one and it it was kby kby I'm not
sure koream barbecue K barbecue short
rib it wasn't short rib it was it was
different cuts it wasn't short rib in
this case it wasn't kby however the meat
comes out and I was like oh because you
know in Japan it's like if you have meat
of rice yeah and I was like oh we're
going to eat rice with it and they're
like well no you kind of have the rice
like a dessert and I was like huh okay
never would have guessed that so you
have the rice at the end at least we did
I'm two for two at this now and had some
what was it it was like fermented
soybean soup towards the end but another
aspect that I had never run into and
this leads to a couple of open questions
for me is I think it was sesame oil and
one of the guys with me was like yeah we
this is kind of our olive oil we dipped
the beef into the sesame oil which had
never done before and I was like okay
the sesame oil was sort of like a
condiment right I was like how how you
dip bread and so you eat this it's
basically just all meat all the time for
a section you have a little bit of
kimchi a little bit of this a little bit
of that and what I loved was also in
this particular case and I think this is
not true everywhere but they were using
charcoal instead of just say some kind
of burner with gas and the heat was so
high that these thick Cuts were cooking
pretty much completely within a handful
of minutes the other thing unique in my
experience with Korea versus anywhere
I've been in East Asia even Central Asia
is you guys use scissors a lot scissors
for the meat scissors for cutting stuff
yeah and by the way that annoys my wife
so much cuz I will just I cook a lot of
barbecue yeah yeah I'm a self-professed
Grill Master for my family I'm I have
meat scissors oh yeah and I'm constantly
clipping yeah why the hell would you use
a knife it makes so much sense have you
seen the Korean meat scissors that have
the bottle cap opener for beer oh that's
genius right in the middle that makes it
makes all the sense in the world yeah
makes all the sense in the world so
Korean barbecue has been amazing and I
would say I was surprised and I
shouldn't be but I came in blank slate
right I really didn't know what I was
going to experience here but if you go
to where you took me for instance to
people hear the word Hyundai and they
think car yeah like lowend car but if
you go to the Hyundai department store
which is super Lux super Delux beautiful
and trust me I'm not a department store
guy but this is like the most beautiful
department store I've ever been in and
the entire basement which is like a city
is this Food Corp but food courtt is a
[__] term for what this is it is
just this NeverEnding sea of culinary
Delights of every variety and the ice
cream the
quasa the
pastries Korea really knows how to do
food the food is spectacular and I think
that that is
actually the most important part of
Korean soft power if we're talking about
this is the export economy yeah it is
the first thing that people loved even
before K-pop food there is not one
person that I've taken to Korean
barbecue for the first time that hasn't
said I cannot believe I've never eaten
this before yeah this is incredible I'll
give you a funny story about Austin your
current city back in
2011 mhm I was down there for South by
Southwest my startup has just launched
it was a music app startup and a friend
from food and wine Magazine asked me if
I wanted to be a contestant in a
barbecue sauce contest in Austin as part
of South by Southwest I said sure I said
what do I need to do well you need to go
out and get your own materials at the
grocery store and then you're going to
compete and we're going to grill
everyone's going to be around there
there's going to be a whole audience and
it's going to be an audience
participation and vote so I was like I
only know how to cook one type of
barbecue but you know I'll try so I
basically did a American barbecue recipe
and I took a cream barbecue recipe which
my mother taught me and I knew like the
back of my hand I could do that in my
sleep so I got soy sauce got sesame oil
I got pears I got like Bartlet pears cuz
they didn't have the Asian pears in
Austin yeah and then brown sugar
Coca-Cola wow uh ca-ca garlic sesame
seeds everything mhm and I made a Korean
barbecue marinade and then I put in like
the tomatoes and I put in I got some
molasses put that in there and I made
this whole big pot and put some onions
in there too just to give it a little
bit more kick and I put in the pot I
didn't describe it to anyone so I made a
Korean barbecue marinade in a Texas
style MH and put in this big pot and I
had a friend there Michael galbert who
was from New York at the time he was
watching me do this whole thing everyone
else had done some sort of like Carolina
barbecue or Memphis barbecue and you go
up and you take these grilled chicken
drumsticks and these baby back ribs that
were unsued and unseasoned but grilled
and people would go try it and everyone
loved it my pot the whole thing was like
whose pot would get lower first and
everyone said what's in that I said soy
sauce sesame oil garlic right I said I'm
sorry I don't have any kimchi for you
but it would just it would just top it
off and so I I really feel like of all
the soft power thanks of all the exports
cultural exports Korean food is the most
important one because incredible look I
will not be that overly proud Korean
Korean American and say this is better
than everyone else I will say that
Korean food is the best food on the
planet I I I've tried everything I love
Japanese food I love Mexican food I love
Italian food French food obviously I'm
fine dining but um and you know I think
Korean food is the original M export
other than the skilled labor from the'
60s and' 70s and whenever you see a
Korean restaurant mhm if you go there
this is like learning Korean when you go
to Soul and you visit Soul if you find a
Korean restaurant in your town mhm
wherever you are go up to them and
practice your Korean yeah and say ask
them what would you eat you can speak
English to them it's fine but say what
would you eat and say I heard that
Koreans have great stews do you have a
stew and these stews Korean food is
comfort food yeah there are a lot of
people trying to make upscale food and
there are people like Cory Lee at benu
and San Francisco and David Chang at
muku that have perfected a upscale
version of Korean food but Korean food
is comfort food it's homecooking food we
had food the other day and I was saying
got to eat the stuff that's like this is
a poor country's food mhm and that's the
best stuff the other stuff is great so
anyways I wanted to give kudos to the
original Korean export that everyone
loves which is Korean barbec Korean
barbecue and Korean food and the stews I
didn't expect to be broadsided by the
stews they're so delicious and fair
warning can get pretty spicy Korean food
can get pretty spicy so you can get
murky you can get murky like you don't
unless you're Korean or unless you've
looked at the recipe in the preparation
kind of don't know what's in
there murky and
you can definitely earn points also just
by speaking a little bit of Korean you
can just say
like you get a thousand points of credit
from any Korean if you try to speak the
language they love it it'll smooth all
rough edges on anything that you're
talking about with them if you try if
you at least try just a word just a word
or two right thank you I guess it's like
yeah it is so you can say if you if you
want to say it's really good or very
good
Chu or Cham oh Cham is a good one or
kangi kangi yeah yeah that's
like and when you when you're eating if
you don't finish it yeah that's a silent
way of saying it wasn't
good I learned this the hard way going
to I flew this is of course this is the
what I do I flew to La then went to San
Diego cuz I wanted to train with a
Korean archery coach because there are a
couple things I'll just mention in
passing we got to talk about why the
sports that Koreans are particularly
good at yeah I mean for a long time
maybe even still break dancing Koreans
were many levels above everybody else I
mean they were by far the best in the
world
archery by far the best in the world
somebody can fact check this but I think
the women's archery gold medal has been
taken by Koreans for every Olympics
since the Koreans started competing it's
like I actually know a lot about why
that's the case on the archery side
because it's like systematized at every
level of education and it's uh a very
big
deal but I went out to he was like you
and me we're going to have dinner and
that's not really the thing you say no
to so I'm like of course we're going to
have dinner so I go out to Korean
barbecue and he ordered so much food I
mean I'm 170 now I used to be at my
highest and I wasn't fat 220 like I can
eat and he buried me in food but then he
said to me like there I still had all
this food in front of me and he's like
yeah you can't leave that b he like you
got you gotta eat that I like okay yeah
that's like he's like you he's like yeah
you can't leave rice un take off your
shoes bow say the food is good finish
your plate and Bowl yeah and all is good
everything's good everything's great
yeah I wanted to talk a little bit about
the be djun film The just talking a
little bit about film we were at
Sundance together in Utah Park City
great City great place best time to go
skiing or snowboarding is during
Sundance because nobody's skiing they're
all they're all the festival and then
the locals don't want to get anywhere
near the place that's right cuz it's
Mayhem we uh premiered our documentary
on just to be clear our is not me and
Steve's oh no sorry the the collective
we are ours uh the great director and
team including Steve Yun actor but also
executive producer on this film with me
and you came to that but I would love to
hear some of your thoughts on this
because he is the most famous Korean
artist well why don't you tell people
the title the title of the documentary
of this Korean artist is Moon is the
oldest
TV it's on Apple and it'll be on Netflix
probably by the time this podcast comes
out which will be great and the quick
background the high level background is
namjun Pik or in Korean we would say
pnam Jun because we say the last name
first pnam Jun is the most famous Korean
artist of the 20th century was the
father of digital and video art so
whenever you see like TVs all set up in
an array like
dis yeah and um he did the TV Buddha
which is probably his most famous work
with a camera constantly taking video on
a cath R Tu of a sitting Buddha statue
and the Buddha's looking at himself and
he coined the term information Super
Highway and kind of predicted social
media he is a well regarded in the art
world but not really known outside which
is kind of interesting so it's a film
out of passion for his story and you got
to see it so I would love to hear kind
of you coming in without knowing I I
don't think you knew about him yeah I
knew very little about him I mean really
just what you had told me and I really
enjoyed the window
into his personal story as creative
process his Insanity on some level in
the sense that he was highly
experimental also and this is true for
so many artists and innovators deeply
tortured might be too strong a word but
I went through some very difficult times
had very little money at points I
remember the footage of his one of his
Apartments just caving in and like water
coming through the ceilings and the
difficulty in forging a path and
experimenting when you're not getting a
lot of
Applause from any majority
whatsoever
and how incredible
trying that is because it's one thing to
be say an entrepreneur in Silicon Valley
in a culture where the risk taker is
lionized and even failure on some level
in many levels is accepted where you'll
be applauded for trying versus what he
was doing which is true I think for most
people in most cultures and most times
which is really operating at The Fringe
with other people who are doing this
type of
experimentation not just artists but
also
technologists and taking the path less
travel which is really really painful at
times and in many instances not
financially rewarding so I was just
impressed with his tenacity and he's
also just such a character and I said
this to you the other day but one of my
favorite one of my favorite lines was
you know n tun Pike spoke many languages
none of them well and it's just he spoke
a lot of languages but they were all
broken he spoke pish he spoke pish and I
found that so endearing real endearing
guy as well well his story is really
interesting he is one of those
breakthrough moments for Korean culture
and Society in that he was the only
internationally known artist in the 70s
80s '90s and even into the 2000s and
then he passed away in that decade he
was the Ambassador or the representative
as crazy as he might have seemed to
everyone M that in the art world he was
appreciated admired and followed for
that and it's very un Korean for that
time period you have to remember that at
that time period Korea was under
essentially a dictatorial a somewhat
elected Administration And to clarify
for folks also me he was outside of he
was in Germany he was in the US you he
part of the diaspora yeah he was part of
the diaspora if he had done what he was
doing in Korea he would have been
censored it was too weird it was too out
there it was too counter poitical on own
specs and even when he visited you saw
that footage he was nervous that he
would not be able to leave Korea and
that he would get locked up yeah when he
visited much later right but they
embraced him which is really interesting
because if he had done all that here he
would have been shut down but the fact
that he did it out on the world and
became well known right and did these
live broadcasts that ended up looking
like the Future YouTube variety show I
forgot about some of those oh my God
yeah I mean in the show notes you got to
put a link to this and there's there's a
there's a a free streaming link I think
somewhere so it won't be about like a
commercial thing but he became such a
popular figure in Korea despite doing
that out there and it was something that
if he had done it here it would have
been panned right yeah and maybe
censored right and I think that that is
part of that Han he struggled with
mental health yeah big time with
relationships with his own art and his
own identity and
failure and in a weird way it's sort of
a he represented the unexpected hero to
a lot of artists and thinkers of the
time there was a thing in Korean music
before K-pop there was an extremely
underground small but amazing Jazz and
rock scene especially psych Rock there
was a band called high five and high six
what is that I mean the best version of
inagada Dita is an obscure Korean psych
rock band what is psych rock this is
just a genre that I'm not familiar with
psych rock is psychedelic Rock right oh
I got it okay and psychological Rock the
70s when that was popular in the US yeah
Koreans were doing that but here's the
thing government sensors mhm back then
would shut down anything that looked a
little suspect edgy and yeah counter to
The Counter Culture yeah represented
Counter Culture at the time so they
would put out these album covers on the
LPS that looked like flowers and blue
sky and clouds and just really weird
fluffy covers right but the music inside
was
serious and it was it was trippy it was
intense yeah and so like Little House on
the Prairie on the front and then
romstein on the inside yeah it's like
judge this book by its cover please CU
inside is some really like you know
subversive stuff not only subversive but
they were dancing to this enjoying this
inside of small clubs and bars and
Apartments because this couldn't be a
thing that you could do in a Big Concert
Hall the government sensors were there
right yeah so I want to call out that
the diaspora is really important to a
lot of what's happened too so if you
look a lot of K-pop a lot of K-pop
people are coming back from the
US and coming back from other countries
where they've learned something another
culture and they're bringing it back and
they're adding to it here yeah so a lot
of the dance groups I actually sponsored
the first world B boy championships
called R16 ino in 2008 no I'm kidding
yeah didn't know that and all the best B
boy Crews from around the world France
it was all country based like an
Olympics it's like France versus Japan
US versus Korea right and everyone
convened Ino outskirts of soul and was
government supported which is the
craziest thing and it was an incredible
moment but it was very clear that dance
culture here which is very strong today
MH came from the Korean
gilp that had come back they brought it
from New York they brought it from LA
and they brought it back and improved it
yeah and cooking the same thing MH
there's a lot of uh chefs that have come
back from the US or France or UK come
back this whole so there's this export
but then there's also this reverse
immigration happening where they're
coming back so it's a really exciting
time to be in whole startups are rising
MH and that's now a new career option
there's still huge problems with North
and South Korea the tension and the
geopolitical like fear and anxiety that
happens but there's something really
Dynamic and it feels like we don't know
how long this will last MH not just
because of like the danger of
geopolitical stuff but also because
of does it get dialed in like Tokyo one
day mhm and becomes everything gets
really locked in defined just in imov
like stasis yeah yeah and right now it
feels really like
transitional yeah I mean it feels to me
at least and look I've only been here 5
days so what do I know but I pay a lot
of attention to First Impressions and it
just has a very
alive feeling to it it has similar to
the way that in a sense like the way
Austin feels right now has like an
adolescent growth feeling to it there's
a lot of energy and there's a lot of
velocity like there there's many things
being built many at least I'm speaking
about Austin now like restaurants being
open companies being started people
moving companies there lots of people
moving there for the cultural stuff it
has a feeling of being pregnant with
possibilities which is the vibe that I
get here walking through these
neighborhoods I'm like okay yeah I bet
if I come back here in three five years
like totally differ 70% of these stores
will have changed I mean there'll be a
lot of differences the director Amanda
Kim of the documentary The Dungeon peek
documentary she lived in New York and
she lives in Paris now we did a premere
screening here and she said that it was
so emotional even though she hasn't
spent a lot of time in Korea so
emotional to have been the director to
present to Koreans this film about the
most important artist of all Korean
people in the modern era to present that
back and she said it was just a not only
a mind-blowing experience for her as a
director but as a Korean gilo coming
back to present that and so this is
something that I think a lot of you know
any of your listeners who are
korean-american or Asian-American or
even from India and thinking about that
reverse brain drain as they call it yeah
the cycle like the cycling back the
feedback loop so important mhm one thing
we were eating Mandu the other day mhm
Mandu is a Mongolian word that's
Mongolian word China uses certain parts
of China use Mandu Korea uses Mandu
turkey uses Mandu Pakistan us Mandu food
is the original spice food carried by
Mongolians Romans it's the original
cultural export yeah Korean food
Korean film Korean music Korean beauty
all of this is the only thing that will
keep Korea alive in perpetuity MH this
could all be gone mhm it's too small of
a country too small of a population on
too tenuous of a peninsula literally in
the geographic center M of all the
tension in the
region so that export that pollen
that is the existence right yeah totally
and so it's it's um on the concept of
you know whether it's what's happening
right now with the technology industry
here
Arts food like all of that it feels
really like it's peeking there's this
kwave across all these things and uh I
can't think of a more exciting time to
be here than literally right now yeah
and for the next 5 10 years if I didn't
have a family that's in schools and a
fund that is headquartered in San
Francisco mhm this would be the best
place definitely in asah MH it's like
groaning and squeaking and screaming as
burs yeah I really encourage people to
check it out and also to paint a picture
we're sitting in this hotel room looking
out beautiful sunny day which is crazy
cuz it was snowing earlier you were
saying as soon as you think you got to
figure it out like Korean weather really
[__] with you it's all over the place
but it's this beautiful sunny day right
now and there's this gorgeous mountain
range right outside the window and so it
has this feeling of reminds me in a
sense of say a Sal Lake City where you
have the wasach and this beautiful range
which I also did not expect and it
totally changes the feeling in the city
knowing that you can look up at least in
this neighborhood and see these
mountains it's a stunning City
and hopefully this puts it on the map
for some people as a possibility for
visiting I will also say huge
difference experientially for a native
English speaker here say compared to
Japan all du respected Japan I love
Japan I've spent a ton of time there but
the English level is higher here so it's
easier to get around and interact and
make requests and solve problems and so
on so that is also a huge benefit to the
International Community is I've just
found it much easier
to my my Korean as hard as I might try
in a handful of days still pretty
limited so I do need to to lean on the
English anything else that we should
cover before we wind to a close anything
else you'd like to say before we land
the
plane I think we're good what do you
think I think we're good I think we're
good man and thanks for having me oh so
fun it's been a fun week it's been a
great week we've covered a lot with a
short amount of time but still some more
to come yeah we've got some more
adventuring to do and to everybody
listening as always I'll put links to
everything that we can pull from this
conversation links to everything we
discussed in the show notes at tim. Blog
podcast and also as always until next
time be just a bit nicer a bit Kinder
than is necessary not just to other
people little bit to
yourself
and thanks
listening hey guys this is Tim again
just one more thing before you take off
and that is five bullet Friday would you
enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday that provides a little fun
before the weekend between 1 and A2 and
2 million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet Friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that I send out every Friday to
share the coolest things I've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles I'm reading books I'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that get sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcast guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then I test them and then I share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about if
you'd like to try it out just go to tim.
blog Friday type that into your browser
tim. blog Friday drop in your email and
you'll get the very next one thanks for
listening this episode is brought to you
by givewell there are more than 1.5
million nonprofit organizations in the
United States and millions more around
the world it is very hard to separate
the single from the noise so what I mean
by that is how do you know which few
could actually make a big impact with
your donation rather than frittering it
away with operational expenses and
ineffective initiatives well givewell
has done the hard work givewell was
founded to help donors answer that
question precisely they pour over
independent studies and charity data to
help donors direct their funds to
evidence back organizations that are
saving and improving lives givewell has
now spent more than 15 years researching
charitable organizations and they only
direct funding to a few of the highest
impact opportunities that they found in
global health and poverty alleviation
more than 100,000 donors including yours
truly have used givewell to donate more
than $1 billion which includes
$45,900 th000 lives and improve the
lives of Millions more give well wants
as many donors as possible to make
informed decisions about high impact
giving and you can find all of their
research and recommendations on their
website for free you can make tax
deductible donations to their
recommended funds or Charities and give
well does not take a cut if you've never
donated through givewell before
definitely check it out you should
absolutely take a look at it you can
have your donation also matched up to
$100 before the end of the year or as
long as matching funds last so to claim
your match and to learn more go to
givewell dorg and pick podcast and enter
the Tim Ferris show at checkout make
sure that they know you heard about give
well from the Tim ferah show to get your
donation matched one more time that's
give well g i v w l lgw well.org to
learn more or donate this episode is
brought to you by Nordic Naturals the
number one selling fish oil brand in the
US more than 80% of Americans that's
probably a lot of you listening
including me because I do measure my
Omega-3s do not get enough omega-3 fats
from their diet that is a problem
because the body cannot produce Omega-3s
an important nutrient for cell structure
and function Nordic Naturals solves that
problem with their doctor recommended
and in fact this brand was recommended
to me by one of my doctors Ultimate
Omega fish oil formula so the Ultimate
Omega fish oil formula for heart health
brain function immune support and more
it's incredibly pure and fresh with no
fishy aftertaste so I have been taking
Ultimate Omega for the last 2 months or
so and this fishy aftertaste issue has
been a problem for me and it's actually
with other brands induced some nausea
after a few days and Ultimate Omega has
been as clean as a whistle I've had no
issues whatsoever and if you are
vegetarian or prefer to alternate I
ended up alternating two products and
that is number one the Ultimate Omega
fish oil formula and also the algae
Omega which is plant-based EPA and DHA
that's also from aortic Naturals so I
ended up getting both of those products
and it has improved my recovery from
workouts it's improved my sleep it has
improved my mood and I know that because
I pulled out a lot of other variables in
any case back to the read all Nordic
Naturals fish oil products are offered
in the triglyceride molecular form the
form naturally found in fish and the
form your body most easily absorbs their
ultimate omega fish oil is offered in
soft gels liquid and zero sugar gummies
Nordic Naturals fish oils are friend of
the sea certified and sustainably made
in a zero waste facility powered by
biofuel they're also non-GMO and third
party tested surpassing the strictest
International standards for Purity and
freshness want proof you can visit their
website where they provide certificates
of analysis for every one of their
products so go to
.c and discover why Nordic Naturals is
the number one selling omega-3 brand in
the US and while you're there use promo
code Tim tiim for 20% off of your order
that's
ndc.com and code Tim for 20% off of the
fish oil with no fishy aftertaste all
upside no downside try it out these
statements have not been evaluated by
the Food and Drug Administration this
product is not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any
disease